Wir wissen, dass bei den vielen Kunden, die es gibt, rund 80 Prozent die ganz normalen User des Internets sind und jeder, der jetzt zuhört, kann eigentlich sich selber fragen, wen kenn ich, wer sperren im Internet aktiv umgehen kann. Die müssen schon deutlich versierter sein. Das sind die 20 Prozent, die sind zum Teil Schwerpedokriminelle, die bewegen sich in ganz anderen Foren, die sind versierte Internetnutzer natürlich auch geschult im Laufe der Jahre in diesem widerwärtigen Geschäft. Da muss die Polizei rein und wir lesen ja auch immer wieder, wenn solche Ringe gesprengt worden sind, aber ganz am Anfang in der Prävention, also im Verhindern, dass es überhaupt losgeht, da ist unsere Arbeit.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 124, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute soll es mal um, nicht unbedingt um was ganz anderes gehen, aber zumindest will ich mal ein vergleichsweise aktuelles Thema aufgreifen. Ihr werdet ja sicherlich alle mitbekommen haben, dass es derzeit sehr wild dahergeht rund um die Einführung von sogenannten Internetsperren, da ist dann von Kinderpornografie die Rede und vielen anderen Bedrohungen, die einem so im Internet und sonst wo über uns kommen. Und ja, es gibt da eine starke politische Lobby, die uns vor allem Bösen beschützen möchte, was ja durchaus auch mal ein herer Ansatz ist. Allerdings sind die Methoden extrem umstritten. Und weil das eben so eine komplizierte Diskussion ist und auch weil sie jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch schon eine interessante Fahrt aufgenommen hat, von der man wahrscheinlich so vor kurzem noch nicht so richtig, mit der man noch nicht so richtig hat rechnen können, möchte ich hier ganz gerne mal ein wenig zurückblicken an den Anfang dieser ganzen Diskussionen und auch so halb chronologisch uns da mal so durchzuarbeiten, um einfach nachvollziehen zu können, welche Argumente hier eigentlich auf beiden Seiten im Raum sind, was hier eigentlich wirklich so passiert ist und was man so argumentativ in dieser Diskussion alles noch mit einbringen kann. Ja und dazu begrüße ich scusi, hallo, Florian Walther auch im normalen Leben, als scusi und das scusiblog.de auch fleißig am Bloggen zu diesem Thema. Entschuldigung, ich bin gut informiert, was? Ja, scusiblog.org, genau. Da bloggst du auch schon seit einiger Zeit, weil du bist ja auch schon seit einiger Zeit im Internet und den Computerdingen unterwegs. Wann bist du so in den Topf gefallen?
In den Blogtopf meinst du jetzt?
Ne, so in den Internet-Computertopf.
Ziemlich früh. Also ich habe eine vierstellige Kundennummer bei Xs4all.
Oh, nicht schlecht. Das heißt?
Na, das heißt so 90 oder so was.
90? Und da warst du noch ganz klein und dann hast du aber mit Internet losgelegt.
Klein war ich da noch, da war ich so Schulzeit irgendwie, siebte Klasse oder achte oder so was. Computer hatte ich schon, naja, aber kein, der internetfähig war. Ich musste mir immer den Laptop von meinem Papa leihen, um mal ins Internet zu kommen. Und ich habe mir den Internetzugang auch praktisch mit meinem Vater geteilt. Der wollte auch unbedingt einen.
Ja.
Und naja, dann habe ich gemerkt, dass Xs4all eben auch Einwahlknoten in Belgien hat, die man zum Ortstarif nutzen konnte, obwohl die eigentlich in Holland saßen. Aber man konnte sich immer schon in Belgien auch einwählen. Naja, und dann habe ich mit meinem Papa zusammen einen Xs4all-Account besorgt.
Und da hast du in Belgien gewohnt?
Ich habe mal in Brüssel gewohnt, fünf Jahre.
Ja, Xs4all, kann man vielleicht nochmal erläutern, ist ja einer der wenigen Provider, die halt so aus der Internet-Hacker-Community heraus entstanden sind.
Der erste in Europa, soweit ich weiß, der überhaupt Internetzugänge an jedermann vergeben hat.
Also es gab schon Internetprovider in irgendeiner Form, aber es waren halt die ersten, die wirklich genau an Privatpersonen-Accounts vermittelt haben, sind dann auch sehr schnell sehr groß geworden, sind dann irgendwann verkauft worden, was da, ja, den Helden der ersten Stunde auch den Nachmittag versilbert hat. Nichtsdestotrotz ist Xs4all auch immer noch recht community-nah geblieben, soweit man das aus der Ferne beurteilen kann. Aber darum soll es jetzt gar nicht mal gehen, obwohl auch Xs4all ja so über die Jahre seine liebe Not hatte, mit Zensierern und anderen Organisationen. Da gab es populäre Auseinandersetzungen mit Scientology und so. Vielleicht mal auch ein Thema hier für eine spätere Sendung. Darauf wollen wir uns jetzt erst mal nicht konzentrieren. Also mit anderen Worten, du bist eigentlich auch so ein Hacker, so ein Böser.
Ja, genau. So kann man das, glaube ich, sagen. Also Hacker auf jeden Fall, böse er nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Sache des Standpunktes des Betrachtes.
Das glaube ich auch. Ja, und eigentlich hast du sofort dich hin programmiert und wolltest nichts Böses und dachtest auch, das geht mich alles nichts an.
Ja, also mit dem Thema Zensur hatte ich ja schon mal so ein bisschen am Rande zu tun, die Sachen, die es bei XS4ALL gab, die du erwähnt hast. Da gab es ja auch den Fall mit der Radikal, die in Deutschland verboten war und da auf dem Server lag. Dann gab es da noch eine andere Seite in Deutschland, die bei AOL gehostet war, auch so was aus dem linken Milieu. Die wurde von AOL kommentarlos und ohne Vorwarnung gelöscht, weil man sie für strafrechtlich relevant hielt. Die habe ich mal eine Zeit lang auf meinem XS4ALL-Account gemirrored. Ja, ich habe den halt vorher Bescheid gesagt, hey Leute, da gibt es folgenden Fall. Ich mirrore das jetzt mal nur, damit ihr euch nicht wundert, wenn da bei euch Sachen aufschlagen. Der Provider war ganz cool, der XS4ALL hat einfach gesagt, ja gut, wir haben es registriert, vielen Dank, mach mal. Ja, ist auch nichts passiert. Ja, also so diese ganze Zensursache habe ich schon so ein bisschen mitverfolgt. Ja, die Fälle, die es so im Internet gab und von dem man so gehört hat, auch die Sache mit den Website-Sperrungen von dem Herrn Büsow, habe ich natürlich mitbekommen und auch so verfolgt und so. Aber mit dem dokumentierten Missbrauch von Kindern sozusagen, das was man landläufig Kinderpornografie nennt, obwohl dieses Wort total scheiße ist, weil Pornografie irgendwie nichts mit der Gewaltigung von Kindern zu tun hat sozusagen und in meinen Augen ist das definitiv keine Pornografie, sondern eben dokumentierter Missbrauch und deswegen verwende ich dieses Wort auch meistens und versuche Kinderpornografie nicht zu verwenden. Die ganzen Leute, die in dem Bereich arbeiten, Ermittler, aber auch Leute von Kinderhilfsorganisationen, also welchen, die den Namen verdienen, nicht so was wie die deutsche Kinderhilfe, die reden auch nur von dokumentierten Missbrauch und so, die benutzen das Wort Kinderpornografie auch nicht, weil es deformierend gegenüber den Betroffenen ist. Gut, aber manchmal ist es hilfreich, es zu benutzen, um Leuten schnell zu erklären, um was es geht.
Weil sie einfach den anderen Begriff nicht verstehen.
Genau, und weil das in den Medien eben auch schon jetzt so durch ist, obwohl ich es nach wie vor für falsch halte, das so zu nennen. Ja, nee, damit hatte ich noch nie was zu tun. Ich habe einmal, ich weiß nicht wann das war, so vielleicht Ende der 90er oder so, habe ich einmal ein Bild irgendwo auf so einer Porno-Seite gesehen, wo ein kleines Kind mit drauf war und habe das bei so einer Meldestelle gemeldet und ja, was da richtig passiert ist, habe ich mich gar nicht drum gekümmert. Also ich habe noch mal hinterher nachgeguckt, so zwei, drei Wochen später, da waren die Bilder immer noch online und ja, keine Ahnung, das war das einzige Mal, dass ich im Internet sowas überhaupt gefunden habe oder darauf gestoßen bin. Also gefunden ist das falsche Wort.
In der öffentlichen Diskussion wird ja behauptet, dass es sich um eine massenhafte Verbreitung handelt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also Tim, du bist ja auch schon lange im Internet unterwegs, hast du sowas schon mal durch Zufall entdeckt?
Ich kann nicht mal den einen Fall jetzt verpfeilen, wobei ich auch sagen muss, sich selbst jetzt mit solchen besonderen Netzkenntnissen und spezifischen Interessen dann immer wiederum als Beispiel in Szene zu setzen, ist natürlich auch unangemessen, weil wir eigentlich immer sehr genau wissen, wo wir hin wollen und wir vertippen uns auch nicht so schnell, nicht wahr? Es mag andere Gewohnheiten geben, aber von massenhaft kann ich insofern auch nichts feststellen, als dass, wenn es glaube ich wirklich so wäre, dann würde man da auch häufiger zumindest von dritten mal auch darauf aufmerksam gemacht werden.
Ja, das stimmt. Also, naja, also ich frage halt trotzdem gerne, wenn ich vor großem Publikum stehe oder so, wie viele Leute im Saal sowas überhaupt schon mal zu Gesicht bekommen haben und so. Und naja, die Meldungen sind immer sehr übersichtlich, sagen wir mal. Da melden sich schon ein paar Leute und sagen, ich habe sowas schon mal irgendwie gesehen oder zu Gesicht bekommen. Aber es ist immer eine Handvoll oder höchstens zwei in einem richtig großen Saal. Und naja, dass es öffentlich übers Web verbreitet wird, ohne dass es sich da um eine geschlossene Gruppe handelt oder dass es wenigstens versucht wird, zu verstecken. Ja, das glaube ich nicht so richtig. Also da ist auch, denke ich, der Verfolgungsdruck zu hoch. Also hoffe ich zumindest. Aber ja, da können wir ja nachher noch mal ein bisschen drüber reden.
Ja, aber was, wenn du jetzt immer so der Außenstehende bist, wie ist es dazu gekommen?
Also ich meine, es gab am 20. November 2008 gab es diesen Presseartikel. Ich glaube, ich habe es bei Spiegel online gelesen. Genau. Wo die Frau van der Leyen, die Familienministerin, gefordert hat. Hier die Überschrift von dem Artikel war, von der Leyen will Kinder-Porno-Seiten sperren. So das habe ich in der Presse gelesen Ende letzten Jahres und habe mir gedacht, irgendwie das passt doch alles nicht. Warum wollen die das jetzt sperren? Warum nehmen die das Zeug nicht offline? Illegal ist es doch schon. Ja, kann doch nicht so schwierig sein, die versuchen hier über eine Hintertür-Filter-Infrastruktur zu bauen, war mein erster Gedanke. Eine Woche später oder zwei Wochen später hat die von der Leyen ein Interview, ich glaube der Leipziger Volkszeitung oder so gegeben und hat halt gesagt, dass auch wenn die Internet-Experten und alle anderen sagen, dass das irgendwie der falsche Weg ist, solche Sperren und dass man lieber den Content aus dem Netz kriegen muss und die Täter verfolgen muss und so, hat sie irgendwie Zitat, ich bin fest entschlossen und von dieser Bahn bringt mich auch keiner mehr ab. Die ganze Nummer habe ich kommentiert mit Moody ist beratungsresistent und auch noch stolz drauf. Fand ich unmöglich von der Politikerin, dass sie irgendwie, also dass sie eine Idee hat und was tun will, ist ja schön und gut. Aber wenn ja die ganze Welt sagt, liebe Uschi, das klappt so nicht, das ist der falsche Weg, das ist uneffizient, das hat enorme Kollateralschäden für den Rechtsstaat und so weiter und so fort, macht das nicht, das macht man anders. Und sie sagt, es mir echt egal, ich bin da fest entschlossen, ich mache das jetzt auf Teufel komm raus, egal was es für Kollateralschäden und so weiter, für Nebenwirkungen mit sich bringt, das ist einfach unverantwortlich. Und ein Politiker, der unverantwortlich handelt und irgendwie sein Handeln nicht überdenkt und auch mal die Richtung ändert, wenn er merkt, naja, das war jetzt nicht ganz so richtig, ist untragbar, finde ich.
Man hat auch den Eindruck, dass dem auch überhaupt gar keine besondere Diskussion vorausging. Ich meine, dass man jetzt auf einmal so los schießt mit jetzt, irgendwie auf einmal, heute ist alles ganz schlimm, jetzt müssen wir unbedingt was tun. Freue mich immer, was war gestern eigentlich so?
Na interessant ist ja auch, dass die von der Leyen jetzt kurz vor der Wahl damit ankommt und das so hochkocht irgendwie, ohne dass es wirklich, also man hätte ja vorher schon mal eine Studie machen können, um überhaupt belastbare oder halbwegs belastbare Zahlen zu haben. Sie hatte drei Jahre Zeit in ihrer Amtszeit, um andere Missstände in dem Bereich, die Ausstattung der Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die internationale Zusammenarbeit, vielleicht auch nur der Anstoß einer internationalen Anstrengung, die Straftatbestände mal wenigstens auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner zu bringen. Also in vielen Ländern, sogar innerhalb der Bundesländer in Deutschland, gibt es große Unterschiede in der Verfolgung von kinderpornografischen Schriften. Also manche Bundesländer verfolgen nur Videos und Bilder und lassen Texte außen vor grundsätzlich. Andere Bundesländer wiederum verfolgen auch Texte. Also es ist selbst innerhalb Deutschlands nicht einheitlich, was verfolgt wird. Innerhalb Europas schon mal gleich gar nicht. Da gibt es ja super verschiedene Definitionen. In den einen Ländern sind Anscheinbilder oder künstliche Bilder irgendwie so gerenderte Bilder oder Comic-Zeichnungen oder sowas mit solchen Darstellungen nicht illegal oder nicht vom Gesetz erfasst. In anderen Ländern sind sie es schon. Ja, die Altersgrenzen sind furchtbar unterschiedlich in manchen Ländern. Es gilt alles als Kinderpornografie, was bis 18 geht oder bei uns ist Jugendpornografie. In anderen Ländern, wie zum Beispiel in den Niederlanden oder so, war es bis vor kurzem legal, dass 16-jährige Pornofilme drehen. Und es gab so eine Art sexuelle Volljährigkeit, die man schon mit 16 hatte und nicht erst mit 18. Also selbst da kann man sich innerhalb der Europäischen Union und schon gar nicht mit Ländern außerhalb der Europäischen Union einigen. Was ist eigentlich Kinderpornografie? Was wollen wir wirklich verfolgen? Wo sagen wir, das ist zu schwierig, da haben wir zu große Abgrenzungsschwierigkeiten. Das sagt ja selbst die Polizei, dass bei Jugendpornografie, dass sie das nicht verfolgen wollen, weil das so große Abgrenzungsschwierigkeiten mit sich bringt, dass sie im Endeffekt befürchten, massiv übers Ziel hinauszuschlagen und eben Tausende Jugendliche mit Verfahren überziehen, wie wir das gerade in den USA sehen, Thema Sexting. In den USA gibt es im Moment 10.000 Jugendliche, die ein Verfahren wegen der Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie am Hals haben, weil sie sich selber unter das T-Shirt fotografiert haben oder in die Hose und das ihrem Freund oder ihrer Freundin geschickt haben. Und das nach dem amerikanischen Gesetz als Kinderpornografie gilt. In Deutschland gibt es einen Ausnahmetatbestand. Also die eigene Abbildung von solchen Sachen. Oder wenn derjenige, der auf dem Bild selber drauf ist, die Sachen weiter verbreitet, gilt es nicht als strafbare Handlung. Wenn ich das so richtig verstanden habe, ich bin kein Jurist, aber so müsste es sein.
Ich bin kein Jurist. Manchmal wünscht man sich, einer zu sein. In der Diskussion ist es ja auch nicht immer ganz einfach, da zu unterscheiden. Aber so das Recht am eigenen Bild kriegt hier irgendwie noch mal eine besondere Bedeutung. Ich denke auch gerade, wenn ich mir so kulturelle Phänomene anschaue wie Hentai, also dieser japanische Manga-Porn, wo generell im Manga und generell in der japanischen Kultur halt einfach so dieses Kindliche schon immer drin ist, nicht wahr? Die großen Augen und so. Wir haben ja alle Heidi gesehen, dass es da einfach sehr schwierig ist, da überhaupt auch noch treffende Unterscheidungen zu machen.
Ja, Japan ist ja auch eines der Länder, was ganz lange die entsprechenden Gesetze nicht ratifiziert hat in Sachen Kinderpornografie und Jugendpornografie und sowas. Und es scheint ja auch heute noch in Japan so zu sein, dass es in manchen Kreisen irgendwie bei manchen Managern und sonst, die zum guten Ton gehören, zu scheint, irgendwie eine Freundin oder eine Geliebte zu haben, die ja noch nicht mal ihr Abitur fertig hat, sozusagen. Ja, aber da gibt es, wie gesagt, große kulturelle und auch juristische Unterschiede. Und es wäre meines Erachtens schon viel gewonnen, wenn man sich dann einfach mal mit den, sagen wir mal mit den G20-Staaten, das deckt sich so ungefähr mit den Staaten, die auch nennenswerte Internetinfrastruktur haben, wo man so was hosten könnte, vernünftigerweise. Wenn die sich darauf einigen, auf einen kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, dass sie sagen, ja, also wenigstens alles mit Darstellungen von Kindern unter 14 oder, ja, muss man sich halt auf irgendwas einigen. Das verfolgen wir und da schaffen wir jetzt auch die Gesetze, dass das auch im Internet und auch digital und sonst wie verfolgt wird, dann wäre schon viel gewonnen, weil dann hätte man zumindest für diesen Bereich schon mal eine definierte Grundlage, einen definierten Begriff international und könnte sowas dann eben auch über Grenzen hinweg relativ einfach und effizient verfolgen, weil es ja dann eben in allen Ländern auch diese Definition gibt und wenn man das dann in die Gesetze schreibt und die entsprechenden Gesetze anpasst oder schafft, dann hätte man da auch eine viel bessere Handhabe. Im Moment sagen zumindest die Ermittler, es ist so, dass es Dinge gibt, die in Deutschland verboten sind nach dem Gesetz und als Kinderpornografie laufen, die aber zum Beispiel in den USA unter das Recht der freien Meinungsäußerung fallen, weil da halt jemand eine Geschichte geschrieben hat, fiktiv und da irgendwie so kinderpornografische Elemente oder wie soll man sagen irgendwie?
Missbrauchselemente.
Ja, Missbrauchselemente und irgendwelche pädophilen Fantasien vorkommen und in Amerika ist sowas zum Teil durch die Meinungsäußerung gedeckt in Deutschland. Es sind auch Schriften, also ein Text oder so, egal ob er fiktiv ist oder nicht, vom Straftatbestand betroffen, obwohl die Bundesländer das unterschiedlich handhaben mit der Verfolgung.
Trotzdem ist es ja vollkommen unbestritten, dass es eine sehr breitbandige Ächtungsfront gibt in unserer Gesellschaft, die so stark ist, dass man ja gerade in so einer politischen Diskussion es sehr schwer hat, überhaupt Argumente rüberzubringen, wenn man nicht von vorne rein, ich erinnere mich auf einen Vortrag auf der SICK in Köln, da habt ihr ja auch gleich angefangen, man stellt sich halt erstmal hin und sagt, ja, wir erklären jetzt hier feierlich, wir tun das natürlich jetzt hier auch, dass wir natürlich dagegen sind und dass wir selbstverständlich das alles genauso ächten und mit den generellen Zielen dieser in der Diskussion befindlichen Gesetzesinitiativen ja an sich übereinstimmen, plus dass wir einfach vollkommen anderer Auffassung sind darüber, was der beste Weg ist, um das zu machen. Und wenn man das nicht macht oder wenn man auch nur in irgendeiner Formulierung den geringsten Zweifel, also irgendeine Angriffsschleche bietet, dann ist man ja auch meistens schon total tot. Wir haben das ja auch gesehen hier bei dem Fall von dem SPD-Abgeordneten Taus, der ja seit langer Zeit bekannt ist, dass er sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt. Man könnte unterstellen, dass er sogar fast der Einzige ist, der das tat. Auf jeden Fall weiß man heute, er tat es eben auf eine Art und Weise, die besonders war, dass er eben auch wirklich selber eigene Forschung angestellt hat, versucht hat, diese Szene zu verstehen. Also diese Szene, in der eben Missbrauchs-Doku getauscht wird. Und ich war mal, man muss ja auch ohnehin verschiedene Szenarien unterscheiden. Es gibt den Missbrauch, der meistens sowieso in familiellen Kontexten stattfindet. Dann fällt hier und da halt da Bildmaterial an, Videomaterial an.
Wobei auch die Kriminalstatistik von BKA ist da sehr aufschlussreich. Wenn man sich das genau anguckt, dann sind es nur ganz wenige Fälle von den Gesamtmissbrauchsfällen, die überhaupt dokumentiert werden. Also es ist nur ein Prozent ungefähr von den Fällen, wo es zum Missbrauch kommt, wo es dann auch Bilder oder Videoaufnahmen oder sowas Vergleichbares gibt. Also 99 Prozent aller Missbrauchsfälle finden, wie du schon gesagt hast, in der Familie statt im persönlichen Umfeld. Das sind Leute, die die Betroffenen gut kennen oder die oft auch mit ihnen verwandt sind. Und nur in einem Prozent dieser Fälle gibt es überhaupt eine Dokumentation des Missbrauchs. Also 99 Prozent der Fälle, der überwiegende Großteil findet, in den Familien statt und es gibt nie Bilder, die irgendwie im Internet auftauchen könnten. Deswegen wird man über die Verfolgung der Internet-Bilder und so was auch die Opfer der 99 Prozent, also der überwiegende Mehrheit der Fälle, die es in Deutschland gibt, nicht identifizieren und finden können. Was die Polizei ja immer sagt, dass das ihre große Waffe ist oder der große Vorteil, dass sie eben anhand der Bilder und Videos Opfer und Täter versuchen können zu identifizieren und damit noch andauernden Missbrauch von Kindern in ihrer Familie zum Beispiel zu beenden. Und es gibt ja auch durchaus Fälle, wo das es gut und eindrucksvoll gelungen ist und wo die Polizei wirklich sowas geschafft hat. Also die Norweger haben so einen Fall vor kurzem gehabt, die sind auf ein Video aufmerksam gemacht worden, wo zwei kleine Mädchen irgendwie vergewaltigt werden und haben die Tonspur isoliert und das an Interpol gegeben und die haben gemerkt, dass es flämisch ist, haben das an die belgische Polizei übergeben. Die belgische Polizei, die Sprachexperten konnten rausfinden, dass es sich um einen Dialekt aus der Gegend um Brügge handeln muss. Und dann rauf hin ist die belgische Polizei an alle Schulen in Brügge und Umgebung gegangen und hat die Mädchen, die in dem Film zu sehen waren, gesucht und hat sie auch gefunden und hat sie dem Vater entziehen können, der sie missbraucht hat und diese Videos hergestellt hat. Das ist natürlich ein Idealfall, wenn es so läuft.
Ja, es gab aber noch diesen anderen Fall, fällt mir gerade ein. Ich glaube mit diesem Typen, der sich nach Thailand verzogen hatte, der Bilder, wo er auch selber drauf war, veröffentlicht hat, wo er dann meinte, er würde sich gut verstecken, indem er da so einen Spiraleffekt reinrechnet und hat nicht bedacht, dass man einen Effekt, den man reinrechnen kann, zumindest einen solchen, der nicht so destruktiv ist, wie er vielleicht dachte, auch wieder rausrechnen kann. Und dann hatte man sein Foto und irgendwann hatte man auch ihn. Ja, also es ist durchaus möglich. Trotz alledem scheint mir das immer noch was ganz anderes zu sein, als diese Industrie, von der gesprochen wird. Ich meine, das Wort Industrie ist ein sehr stampfendes Wort. Das würde ja bedeuten, dass im Prinzip für einen Bedarf, der da ist, sozusagen die Produkte überhaupt erst erzeugt werden und da sozusagen jetzt kein Überschuss verkauft wird. Das würde ja sozusagen implizieren, dass es da so Keller gibt, wo halt Kinder gehalten werden und Aufnahmen gemacht werden. Gibt es da Erkenntnisse, dass es so etwas wirklich gibt?
Nee, also ich kenne sowas nicht. Also es gibt, also die meisten Anwälte, Strafverteidiger und Leute, die damit zu tun haben, auch Ermittler, sagen, dass diese die Szene oder die Leute, die so Kinderpornografie haben, besitzen, danach suchen, dass die vor allem Jäger und Sammler sind. Also die sammeln halt alles, was sie finden können und tauschen dann mit ihren Freunden, Kumpels, sonst wie diese Bilder aus. Ja, ich gebe dir meine Sammlung, du gibst mir deine Sammlung, so nach dem Motto. Oder ich habe hier einen Satz, krasse Bilder, die du nicht hast, gib mir doch mal den Satz, krasse Bilder, den ich nicht habe.
Also Panini-Sammelbildchen.
Genau, so die Panini-Nummer ist das im Endeffekt. Und das sagen die meisten Anwälte und auch Gerichtsdiener, Staatsanwälte, aus allen Ecken hört man eigentlich, dass in der überwiegenden Mehrzahl der Fälle diese Tauschaktionen unentgeltlich laufen. Was es an Industrie mal gab, war so in den 80er, 90er Jahren gab es halt in Osteuropa, namentlich in der Ukraine vor allem, kommerzielle Produktionen von Posing-Bildern mit Jugendlichen und zum Teil auch mit Kindern. Also so, ja, wo Kinder irgendwie in mehr oder weniger anzüglichen Posen vor der Kamera posieren und davon Fotos gemacht werden und die wiederum verkauft werden oder auf einer Webseite zum Download angeboten werden. Diese Firma hieß LS Studios oder ja, das war ein ganzes Klongomarat, da gab es noch mehr Webseiten und Firmen oder Unterfirmen. Das findet man auch in der Wikipedia zum Beispiel ein paar Sachen drüber und die haben da wohl irgendwie anscheinend gedacht, sie haben eine Marktlücke gefunden oder hatten da auch eine gefunden und haben halt gemerkt, dass man so Sachen teuer verkaufen kann, so Posing-Bilder von Kindern und das waren aber Dinge mit dem Einverständnis der Eltern, also da sind die Eltern mit ihren Kindern hingegangen und haben halt also ein Fotoshooting gemacht, das war auch meistens ohne Ausziehen und sowas, das war angezogen und ja, wobei es da angeblich auch ein paar Bilder geben soll, die so Richtung Bademoden und sowas gehen und ja, das wurde ganz normal bezahlt, da haben die pro Shooting, ich weiß nicht, 40 Euro oder D-Mark oder irgend sowas für bekommen. Ich habe irgendwo mal eine Zahl gelesen, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, müssen wir mal nachgucken. Und die wurden auf kommerziellen Webseiten und so verkauft, diese Bilder. Und da gab es auch Filmchen und man konnte sich die Kinder dann auch für eigene Photosessions mieten sozusagen oder so ein eigenes Shooting in Auftrag geben und sagen, was man sehen will oder so Sachen muss es da auch gegeben haben, nach Beschreibungen, die ich gelesen habe. Und das ist das einzige Kommerzielle, was mir bekannt ist in dem Bereich.
Also jetzt keine Folterkeller, wo nicht mehr missbraucht werden.
Nein, das waren halt so Posing-Bilder.
Das heißt, es spricht schon ein pädophiles Publikum an.
Auf jeden Fall bestimmt.
Aber eben liefert nicht jetzt das Produkt, was hier von der Line ja auch...
Liefert keine Vergewaltigung von kleinen Kindern vor laufender Kamera und sowas. Das nicht. Das sind halt so Posing-Bilder. Also das ist eindeutig dieses Zielpublikum. Ja, ganz klar. Das spricht Leute mit pädophilen Neigungen und so an, die irgendwie auf Kinder stehen und so. Also mehr auf Kinder stehen als das Normale, sagen wir mal, oder?
Ja, ich meine, man könnte auch sagen, die ganze Gesellschaft ist der Jugend zugeneigt, wenn man sich die Werbung anschaut. Ich meine, da wird jetzt in der Regel nicht unbedingt mit Senioren für Produkte geworden.
Nee, außer bei irgendwie hier das mit der Doppelkraft des Herzens.
Na ja gut, da will ich mich jetzt auch gar nicht weiter verstricken in diese Diskussion. Mir geht es jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen darum, vielleicht auch nochmal nachzuvollziehen, was eigentlich bisher passiert ist. Als du dann sozusagen von allein mit ihren Ankündigungen wahrgenommen hast, kocht das bei dir so ein bisschen hoch und du hast dir gedacht, das will ich mir jetzt mal genau anschauen, was da eigentlich läuft. Und du hast dir so Listen besorgt.
Ja, ich dachte mir, das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Und warum sperren die die? Und ist das wirklich so, dass die im Ausland stehen und man da nicht draufkommt? Wo zum Teufel stehen die denn? Ja, und naja, dann habe ich mich auf die Suche begeben und dachte mir, mal gucken, ob es nicht irgendwo so Listen gibt, die öffentlich bekannt sind, was gefiltert wird aus unseren Nachbarländern, aus den skandinavischen Ländern und so weiter.
Genau, also die muss man auch dazu sagen. Das ist ja nichts Neues, sozusagen, diese Forderung, also jetzt im weltweiten Kontext. Es gibt natürlich Länder, die solche Sperren schon haben. Allen voran natürlich immer das leuchtende Beispiel aus China, aber eben beileibe nicht nur das, sondern vor allem in vielen Ländern explizit auch mit derselben Argumentation, dass es Sperrungen sind gegen kinderpornografische Inhalte. Richtig?
Ja, also vor allem in den europäischen Ländern ist das so. Also es gibt natürlich noch viel mehr Länder, die ganz massiv das Internet zensieren. Iran, Saudi-Arabien. Aber die machen das einfach so. Die zensieren auch alles Mögliche. Also da wird auch normale Nacktdarstellungen, da kann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht die Bademoden bei Otto angucken oder so. Da wird auch sonst was, alles, was irgendwie als unislamisch und irgendwie wahrgenommen wird, gefiltert.
Ja, und auch alles, was in irgendeiner Form ihnen sonst wie merkwürdig vorkommt. Ja, also was weiß ich hier, wenn ich mal so ein Vp… Ich hab versucht, mich aus Dubai mit meinem VPN-Provider zu verbinden.
Das ging auch nicht.
War auch schon sehr schwierig.
Tätowierungen zum Beispiel sind da auch nicht so gern gesehen. Das wird auch gerne mal gefiltert. Nee, aber ich hab mich vor allem auf die europäischen Länder konzentriert, die immer in der Diskussion auch schon von Frau van der Leyen und anderen Zensurbefürwörtern als Vorbilder und als Beispiele genannt wurden. Das sind die Skandinavier, Norwegen, Finnland, Schweden, Dänemark.
Weil jetzt sind diese Listen ja total geheim.
Die sind die Niederlande und die Schweiz und Italien. Naja, die Listen sind gar nicht so geheim. Ich bin dann nämlich ziemlich schnell fündig geworden mit der Suchmaschine meiner Wahl. AIX Quick. Ist eine Metasuchmaschine, aber die loggen keine Daten. Die speichern nicht. Bei Wikileaks habe ich dann Sperrlisten von einigen Ländern gefunden. Das größte Problem war, dass die Sperrlisten mitunter bis zu einem Jahr alt waren.
Aus welchen Ländern hast du die dann gefunden?
Also gefunden hatte ich sie bei Wikileaks aus Norwegen, Finnland, Dänemark. Ich gucke gerade mal nach. Ich habe hier eine Liste. Also bei Wikileaks habe ich die von Dänemark vom Februar 2008 gefunden. Die von Finnland hatte ich von Lapsipornoinfo von Martiniki. Das ist der finnische Aktivist, dessen Seite gesperrt ist in Finnland. Der hat die finnischen Zensurlisten mal gecheckt und festgestellt, dass davon nur sehr wenige Prozent überhaupt Bezug zu Kinderpornografie haben. Der Rest ist andere Pornografie oder hat nichts damit zu tun. Der hat auch so eine Liste online stehen. Die habe ich mir von seiner Webseite besorgt. Die Listen aus Schweden habe ich auch von Lapsipornoinfo. Da hat jemand die finnische Liste genommen und die mit Schweden abgeglichen über ausprobieren. Und dann habe ich noch eine Liste in einem Blog in der Schweiz gefunden, was Teil der Schweizer Liste ist, die verwendet wird. Diese Liste aus Dänemark, Finnland, der Schweiz und Schweden habe ich zusammengeführt, doppelte Einträge rausgenommen, die ein bisschen normalisiert. Die schreiben sich das nicht alle im gleichen Format auf. Und manche schreiben HTTP dazu und manche nicht. Und manche schreiben www da vorne dran und andere nicht. Und so habe ich halt ein bisschen normalisiert und habe mir dann ein Perl-Script gebaut, was mir die IPs auflöst, wenn sie denn auflösbar sind, und mit einer Geodatenbank nachschaut, wo auf der Erde diese IPs lokalisiert sind. Also zu welchem Land die gehören, in welchem Land die IPs stehen, die Server stehen. Na und das Script, was ich mir gebaut habe, das steht auch in meinem Weblog zum Download. Das wirft einem halt gleich eine URL für die Google-API aus und da kann man dann draufklicken und dann kriegt man von der Google-API ein schönes Bild, eine schöne Weltkarte gemalt, wo die Länder farblich entsprechend eingezeichnet sind. Ja und das habe ich dann, das hat mich erst mal sehr verwundert.
Warum?
Na, weil wenn man sich das so anguckt, dann sind die Länder, wo solche Server stehen, nicht jetzt irgendwie Timbuktu in Afrika, wo man denken könnte, da gibt es vielleicht nicht so eine Gesetze oder die haben noch gar nicht mitgekriegt, dass es Datennetze gibt und deswegen auch keine Gesetze gegen irgendwas in Datennetzen oder so. Nein, also die USA, Kanada, ein bisschen Mexiko, also die Hotspots, die Sachen, die rot eingezeichnet sind auf meiner Weltkarte, da, wo die meisten Server stehen, das sind die USA, gefolgt von Australien, gefolgt von den Niederlanden, von Deutschland, von Südkorea und von Kanada. Und dieses Bild, also die Top 10 sind eigentlich immer so in dem Bereich, egal, welche Sperrliste man nimmt.
Da, wo das Internet sowieso technologisch schon weit entwickelt ist, wo große Server-Standorte sind.
Genau, wo Hosting günstig ist. Ja, ich meine, weißt du, was Traffic in Afrika kostet? Das lohnt sich einfach nicht. Also selbst Russland ist meistens nicht unter den Top 10, sondern so im Mittelfeld.
Und das, obwohl ja das BKA eigentlich immer wieder drauf hinweist.
Ja, das müssen wir mal sehen. Ich habe gestern Abend eine E-Mail an die russische Botschaft in Deutschland geschickt und habe sie explizit zu diesen Vorwürfen befragt und wollte von ihnen wissen, ob es zutrifft, dass sie keine Amtshilfe leisten, wenn es um Kinderpornografie im Internet geht. Ich wollte von ihnen wissen, ob sie Gesetze dagegen haben und was die Gesetze so hergeben. Und ich hoffe, dass ich eine Antwort bekomme und dass sich die russische Botschaft da mal offiziell zu äußert. Weil nach meinem Wissen gibt es in Russland Gesetze zur Verfolgung von Kinderpornografie, die jetzt nicht ideal sind. Also man liest an vielen Stellen, dass es die durchaus verbesserungswürdig sind und dass es in Russland gerade in Bezug auf Datennetze da noch Gesetzeslücken geben soll. Ich kenne die Gesetze in Russland jetzt nicht selber. Ich kann auch gar kein Russisch. Aber ich dachte mir halt, ich frage mal ganz offiziell bei der Botschaft an, was die denn dazu sagen, dass sie hier hingestellt werden als diejenigen, die nicht helfen wollen. Und ich weiß, dass es zumindest Gesetze gibt, die auch Kinderpornografie in Russland illegal machen und behandeln. Ich glaube, sie haben kein spezielles Gesetz für solche Sachen in Datennetzen. Aber das braucht man unter Umständen auch gar nicht. Je nachdem, wie das Gesetz geschrieben ist, das normale, was es gibt, kann man das ja ohne Probleme auch auf Datennetze anwenden.
Aber jetzt hast du ja gesagt, in diesen Listen ist beileibe jetzt nicht nur Seiten drin, die jetzt den eigentlichen Grund liefern könnten, diese Seiten auch auf die Sites zu nehmen. Ich meine, das könnte jetzt viele Gründe haben. Das könnte bedeuten, dass, ich meine, da stehen ja nur, was steht drin in diesen Listen? Da stehen ja Domain-Adressen drin.
Host-Namen oder Domain-Namen, ja.
Host-Namen. Keine URLs, keine spezifischen Orte.
In der australischen Liste stehen URLs, weil die auch so ein Hybrid-System favoritisieren. Allerdings, lustig genug, haben sie die URLs total häufig falsch geschrieben. Da steht dann htdp.doppel.doppel.backslash. Die sind irgendwie auf Windows. Die schreiben auch nie Slashes als Pfad-Angabe in den URLs, sondern meistens Backslashes. Für die australische Liste habe ich mir extra ein Pearlscript geschrieben, was die URLs normalisiert, weil da so viele Fehler drin waren, dass man es nicht parsen konnte und nix.
Oh man, da fragt man sich ja, wie diese Listen überhaupt als solche...
Na, die australische Liste ist eh vollkommen für die Cats. Also da mussten sie ja jetzt vorgestern oder so im australischen Parlament, gab es eine Anhörung, da musste die Behörde, die die Liste führt, die ACMI, glaube ich heißt die, zugeben, dass überhaupt nur 32 Prozent der Einträge auf ihrer Liste irgendwelchen Bezug zur Kinderpornografie haben. Also das heißt im Umkehrschluss, dass was, 68 Prozent, zwei Drittel ihrer Liste mit Kinderpornografie nichts zu tun haben. Und die australische Liste ist wirklich übel. Also wir haben ja letzten auch diese, jetzt vor ein paar Tagen dieser Aktion gemacht, zu versuchen, so Server selber offline zu nehmen, indem wir Abuse-Mails an die Provider schicken und sie darauf hinweisen. Und die australische Liste hat mit Abstand die meisten False-Positives ergeben. Also bei der australischen Liste kamen auf fast, also auf mehr als jede zweite Antwort kam zurück oder Anfrage kam zurück vom Provider. Also auf der Seite ist gar nichts mit Pornografie und auch nichts mit Kinderpornografie. Und das ist ein Sportverein und das ist alles total legal und tut die.
Muss man vielleicht noch mal kurz dazu erwähnen, für die Leute, die mit diesem System nicht vertraut sind. Also eigentlich ist es so, dass jeder Provider und jeder Betreiber größerer Netzwerke, das betrifft zum Beispiel auch, wenn man Veranstaltungen macht. Also ja, auch das Problem haben wir ja auch, wenn wir Chaos Communication Congress machen, dass man eine sogenannte Abuse-Mail-Kontaktadresse bereitstellt. Also sozusagen auf einer Webseite oder wo auch immer dokumentiert, wenn hier irgend, also von unserem Netz aus oder von unserer Domain aus, was auch immer, wenn ihr irgendeiner Art negative Auswirkungen auf eure Infrastruktur, das können jetzt Hacker-Attacken sein, das kann irgendwie der Content eben sein, der angeboten wird, feststellt, dann gibt es hier einen Abuse-Kontakt. Und man hat, ich weiß nicht inwieweit sowas mittlerweile auch schon Gesetzesfleisch ist. Es ist vor allem erstmal guter Stil und wird auch in der Regel so durchgeführt. Das heißt, man stellt jemanden ab, eine oder mehrere Leute, die auf entsprechende E-Mails unter dieser Kontaktadresse reagieren und dann Maßnahmen einleiten. Und an die habt ihr euch gewendet. Und da gibt es dann auch tatsächlich Kooperation.
Na, wir haben gleich noch einen lange Fragebogen mitgeschickt. Also wir wollten gleich noch von den Providern wissen, ob sie denn von der Polizei schon mal informiert wurden, dass diese Seite auf so einer Sperrliste steht. Wir wollten natürlich wissen über den Content, ob es da so Material gibt oder ob nicht. Ob es da solches Material mal gab oder ob die Seite gehackt wurde. Wir haben einen langen Fragenkatalog mitgeschickt und erstaunlich viele Provider waren auch so freundlich, die Fragen zu beantworten und die Antworten mitzuschicken.
Aber wie einfach könnt ihr denn das prüfen? Ich meine, wenn da jetzt nur eine Domain drinsteht, dann kann das ja, was weiß ich, ein Web-Forum sein mit Millionen von Einträgen, die kriegt man ja nicht.
Ja, das gab es auch in vielen Fällen, dass die Provider gesagt haben, also wir haben jetzt hier auf die Domain geguckt oder auf die Einstiegsseite und wir konnten da nichts finden. Wir haben da auch ein bisschen rumgeklickt und konnten nichts finden. Wenn sie da Hinweise haben oder eine genaue URL, geben sie uns doch nochmal eine genaue URL.
Aber genaue URLs standen ja auch drin in der australischen Liste. Habt ihr die euch mal angeschaut?
In der australischen Liste schon, aber das sind genaue URLs von YouTube-Videos, die nichts mit Pornografie zu tun haben. Naja, wesentlich nicht. Auf der australischen Liste sind ganz sonderbare Beispiele. Auf der australischen Liste ist ein Kinderzahnarzt.
Die Webseite eines Kinderzahnarztes?
Ja, ein Zahnarzt, der spezialisiert ist auf die Behandlung von Zahnschmerzen und Kieferoperationen und sowas bei Kindern. Und dessen Webseite steht auf der australischen Zensurliste für Kinderpornografie.
Das waren sie, die Kinder einfach nur vor Schmerzen bewahren.
Der Hintergrund ist, dass die Webseite mal gehackt wurde und irgendwelche Leute, die die Webseite gehackt haben, haben da wohl Porno-Bilder unter anderem, wohl auch ein paar Bilder, die den Tatbestand der Kinderpornografie erfüllen, hinterlegt.
Das ist natürlich auch nochmal ein Problem, dass einem der Content auch untergejubelt wird.
Genau. Und das wurde dann auch gleich entdeckt. Also es ist übers Wochenende passiert. Der Zahnarzt hat das dann erst montags oder dienstags gemerkt, hat dann bei seinem Provider angerufen. Die haben das Zeug irgendwie da runtergenommen, haben ihm einen neuen Passwort log in und alles gegeben, eine neue Webpräsenz. Er hat seine Homepage da wieder draufgestellt. Ja, der steht bis heute eben auf dieser australischen Sperrliste, weil er da nie wieder runtergenommen worden ist. Und das ist ja auch in Deutschland so nicht vorgesehen in den bisherigen Entwürfen, dass man da irgendwie wieder runterkommt, außer wenn man selber das BKA verklagt. Wo der Zahnarzt in Australien aber womöglich nie merken wird, dass seine Seite beim BKA in Deutschland auf so einer Sperrliste steht und gefiltert wird.
Da muss man nur wundern, warum so viele Leute Probleme haben, seine Webseite zu erwerben.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Also das ist ja was Globales. Und Domains werden ja auch, also wenn die Anbieter merken, dass die Sachen gesperrt sind oder dass da jetzt massiv niemand mehr kommt, oder ihnen massiv der Besucherzustrom einbricht, dann werden die Domains gerne mal geparkt und verkauft. Naja, und wenn ich mir dann bei SEDO oder bei so einem großen Domainanbieter eine geparkte Domain kaufe, das ist ja nicht immer aus den Namen ersichtlich, um was es da geht. Also manche heißen Lolita Teens oder so.com oder weiß nicht, so was da. Kann ich mir schon denken, was dahinter ist. Aber es gibt auch durchaus Domainnamen, die sind völlig nicht-sagend oder zumindest mehrdeutig oder ja, man kann nicht unbedingt draufschließen, was dort zu sehen sein wird. Und wenn ich mir so eine Domain bei so einem Domain-Händler kaufe und die steht auf einer Sperrliste, dann habe ich mir eine Domain gekauft, die zumindest aus Deutschland oder aus Finnland oder wo auch gerade sie auf der Sperrliste steht, niemand erreichen kann. Naja, und bis ich das gemerkt habe und bis ich gemerkt habe, dass es die und die Sperrliste ist und so, dann muss ich da an die Polizei rantreten. Und ja, gerade in Finnland gibt es ja gute Beispiele davon, dass die Polizei sagt, nee, auf der Seite ist nichts Illegales, aber wir lassen sie trotzdem gesperrt.
Weil, warum auch immer?
Ja, weil da die Sperrlisten stehen und kritisiert werden. Also Finnland kritisiert mit dem System selber die Kritiker der Internetzensur.
Sie sperren die Kritiker? Also das heißt, es wird sozusagen nicht der eigentliche Content, um den es geht, wird gesperrt, sondern es wird auch jegliche Diskussion darüber gesperrt.
Ja, das gab es öfters auf den Sperrlisten. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen Fall von einer Seite, die, ich weiß gar nicht, das war, ich glaube, da hat jemand ein Buch geschrieben über Gewalt und Jugendliche und Gewalt zwischen Jugendlichen und so und die wurde auch gesperrt. Auf der dänischen Sperrliste stehen Speditionen aus den Niederlanden, ein Speditionsunternehmen, Fanderhück.nl oder so. Das ist eine Spedition, die verkaufen Lkw-Fahrten quer durch Europa und Laderaum und so was, was so eine Spedition so macht. Die standen auf der dänischen Sperrliste für Kinderpornografie drauf. In Dänemark steht ja auch Pirate Bay mit auf der Sperrliste oder stand eine Zeit lang mit auf der Sperrliste für Kinderpornografie. Ich meine, sowas ist natürlich auch immer einfach. Also wenn ich die Content-Industrie wäre, ich würde mir irgendwo so ein Zeug besorgen und würde das in Torrent machen und den auf Pirate Bay laden und dann bei der Polizei anrufen und sagen hier, genau das Scorpions-Album mit Cover-Foto zum Beispiel. Das reicht ja schon. Also in Großbritannien hat es ja gereicht für die Wikipedia.
Ja oder halt auch wirklich anstößigen Content, wenn man ihn denn hat so und dann halt einfach verbreiten. Also sozusagen die Möglichkeit, andere zu diskriminieren und aus dem Spiel zu bringen, anzuschwerzen.
Das sagen auch viele Kommentatoren, dass wenn diese Sperren so kommen, wie sie beabsichtigt sind und wie sie geplant werden, dann wird das die neue Abmahnwelle im Internet. Also dann wird die nächste Rickrolling-Welle einfach sein, Leute zu versuchen, möglichst oft auf diese Stoppseite zu bringen, so dass das BKA dahergeht und bei denen mal eine Hausdurchsuchung macht, weil die im Monat einfach hundertmal die Stoppseite aufgerufen haben. Und ich meine, das ist ja nicht weiter schwierig.
dafür zu sorgen, dass halt bestimmte Seiten als in der pornographisch eingestuft werden.
Ich habe dir ja vorhin vor unserem Gespräch dieses lustige Cross-Site-Scripting bei der CDU Erzgebirge gezeigt. Damit ging das zum Beispiel.
Wo man sozusagen den Content einfach einblendet, indem man eine Sicherheitslücke in der Webseite ausschließt. Das heißt, da ist dann gar kein Content drauf, aber jemand, der es überprüft, mag nicht sehen, dass das quasi von hinten durch die Busse ins Auge eingefügt wurde und sieht das dann einfach als Beleg an. Und dann ist CDU Erzgebirge auch in der KiPo-Liste und wissen gar nicht warum.
Ja, und sie werden es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schnell merken. Also, ja.
Wie sollen sie auch?
Wie sollen sie auch? Also oft ist es ja auch so, dass Leute ihre eigene Homepage zwar ab und zu updaten und pflegen, aber da selber nicht regelmäßig drauf surfen. Man weiß ja, was drauf steht und so.
Das kennt man ja alles.
Und dann merkt man es erst, wenn irgendwie ein Freund oder Bekannter, der so an so einem Anschluss sitzt, wo die Sperrliste umgesetzt wird, da versucht, drauf zu surfen und entgeistert bei seinem Freund anruft und fragt, wie du hast jetzt Kinder-Pornografie auf deiner Webseite, weil das steht ja auf diesem Stoppschild. Also, der Rufmord ist bei einer falschen Einordnung der eigenen Seite auf dieser Liste schon inklusive. Das muss auch der Matinikki aus Finnland zum Beispiel erfahren. Also, diese Lapsiporno-Info. Lapsiporno ist das finnische Wort für Kinder-Porno. Und er hat halt ein Domain Lapsiporno-Info. Punkt-Info. Punkt-Info, genau. Und da geht es halt um die finnische Sperrliste. Da ist die auch veröffentlicht. Der hat sich auch die Mühe gemacht, eine Analyse zu machen. Der hat die Seiten durchgesurft und hat die immer eingeordnet nach gar nichts strafrechtlich Relevantes. Das ist Pornografie, aber keine Kinderpornografie. Pornografie, aber Jugend- oder homosexuelle Pornografie. Der hat das halt alles mal so katalogisiert. Und Seiten, die wirklich kinderpornografische Darstellungen, Filme oder sowas enthielten, hat er nur ganz, ganz wenige gefunden. Ungefähr ein Prozent der finnischen Liste. Wenn man jetzt Jugendpornografie, anscheinend Jugendpornografie und so ähnliche Sachen, also wenn man den Begriff kinderpornografie sehr großzügig zieht, dann kommt man auf sechs Prozent der Liste in Finnland, die blockiert wird, auf der dann entsprechendes Material auch wirklich zu finden ist. Naja, sechs Prozent ist jetzt immer noch nicht so richtig überzeugend. Das heißt im Umkehrschluss, dass 94 Prozent auf dieser Liste nichts verloren haben.
Das heißt, die Kollateralschäden dieser Sperrlisten ist nachweislich extrem, extrem hoch.
Zumindest in allen Fällen, die wir kennen und all diese Länder, die bei uns als Vorbild genannt werden, da ist es definitiv so, dass die Kollateralschäden also den Nutzen ums Vielfache überbieten. Also ich meine, die sperren sechs Seiten, die wirklich sowas darstellen und sperren zusätzlich noch 94 Seiten, die nichts damit zu tun haben. Und ich meine, das steht ja auch im deutschen Gesetz drin, in Skandinavien machen sie das auch, dass die Seiten, die auf Seiten linken, wo sowas steht, auch mit sperren, obwohl das ja eigentlich nicht nötig wäre, wenn sie nur die Seiten sperren, wo auch wirklich die Bilder und so stehen, dann kommt man halt noch bis auf diese Linkliste oder so und dann klickt man auf den Link und dann kommt das Stoppschild. Ich meine, das würde ja vollkommen reichen. Da wäre ihr Abschreckungseffekt, von dem sie immer reden. Aber trotzdem gehen sie so weit, dass sie sagen, wir sperren auch Seiten, die auf Seiten verlinken, wo sowas liegt.
Die Überbringer der schlechten Nachricht.
Genau. Und wir nennen das ja inzwischen die WikiLeaks-Klausel in dem Gesetz. Weil genau damit kann man eben auch so Veröffentlichungsseiten wie WikiLeaks mit auf die Sperrlisten setzen. Weil der Wiki von WikiLeaks macht aus jeder im Textformat eingereichten Sperrliste automatisch links. Und damit sagt die Polizei, wäre es ein Verweis auf Kinderpornografie, weil ja nun von den 100 Domains auch sechs dabei sind, wo wirklich sowas zu finden ist. Die die Polizei übrigens zwar auf die Liste der Sperren aufgenommen hat, aber nicht aus dem Netz entfernt hat. Das grenzt ja dann auch schon wieder an Strafvereitelung im Amt sozusagen. Wobei die halt dann sich dem Schwarzen Peter gegenseitig zuschieben und sagen, ja wir sind in Finnland und das war ja eine Seite aus den Niederlanden. Und wir haben das Interpol erzählt und jetzt wissen wir nicht, was passiert ist. Also es scheint auch wirklich so zu sein, dass die Polizei nie eine Rückmeldung kriegt, wenn sie Sachen weitergibt an andere Länder oder an so Sammelstellen wie Europol oder Interpol, dass die nie erfahren, was daraus geworden ist. Was halt auch schon mal so ein bisschen ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist.
Gerade Europol hat sich ja in dieser Diskussion auch zu Wort gemeldet.
Ja mehrmals. Also das erste Mal aufgefallen sind sie mir mit ihrer Einstiegsdrogentheorie. Also man kennt ja die Einstiegsdrogentheorie noch aus den 80er Jahren, aus der Drogendiskussion. Da hieß es ja auch immer, man kann Cannabis nicht legalisieren, weil das ist eine Einstiegsdroge und das würde dann von, wer Cannabis nimmt, nimmt dann irgendwann auch Ecstasy und Kokain und Heroin und man endet dann sozusagen als Junkie. Also man ganz nebenbei bemerkt, wenn die Einstiegsdrogentheorie stimmt, dann ist die Einstiegsdroge Nummer eins Muttermilch, weil da ist Zucker drin, das ist süß, das ist auch ein Suchtstoff. Und Leute, die Muttermilch bekommen haben, die werden hinterher auch rauchen, Alkohol trinken, Cannabis nehmen, wohlmöglich Kokain und Schlimmeres. Genau. Also noch dazu sind diese Schlüssel, die man so zieht. Ich meine, jeder, der Muttermilch hatte, macht auch hinterher einen Führerschein. Aber deswegen tut man mit der Muttermilch nicht das Führerscheingehen aufnehmen oder irgendwie so was. Die Schlüsse stimmen auch nicht. Aber ganz abgesehen davon hat der Europol-Chef gesagt, dass Leute durch Kinderpornografie angefixt würden und dass, wenn jemand zufällig auf so eine Seite kommt und so was noch nie vorher gesehen hat, dass er es dann plötzlich geil findet und immer weiter danach sucht, immer mehr will die Fantasien in ihm wachsen und er am Ende wie ein Kind vergewaltigt.
Obwohl ja in der Diskussion immer so hochgehalten wird, wie abschreckend und ekelerregend diese Bilder ja seien. Ich meine, da muss man sich auch mal festlegen, ob die nun abschreckend und ekelerregend sind oder ob die nur neue Täter heranziehen.
Also ich glaube das nicht, für mich hört sich das so, ist das Mumpitz, wenn jemand so eine Vorliebe hat und so pädophile Neigungen und auf sowas irgendwie steht, dafür empfänglich ist, dann gibt es wohl möglich Fälle, wo derjenige selber noch nicht weiß oder ihm noch nicht so richtig klar ist, dass er solche Neigungen hat, dann sieht er sowas mal und merkt irgendwie, dass dabei ihm was abgeht und er merkt, dass er diese Neigungen hat. Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Das ist bestimmt bei Leuten, die schwul sind und das noch nicht wissen und dann irgendwie merken, dass es sie beim Duschen im Fußballclub irgendwie erregt, wenn da lauter andere nackte Männer um sie rumstehen.
Aber ich glaube, da tut es auch jeder Spielplan.
Ja, genau. Und naja, also das kann ich mir ja noch vorstellen, aber dass jemand, der überhaupt nicht auf so gepolt ist, auf sowas überhaupt nicht steht, keinerlei pädophile Neigungen hat oder so, dass der so ein Bild sieht, also der fängt vielleicht an zu kotzen, dem wird schlecht, der braucht danach erst mal psychologische Betreuung oder muss da mindestens mit jemanden drüber reden, aber dass der dann irgendwie plötzlich zum pädophilen Kindervergewaltiger wird, das leuchtet mir nicht so richtig ein, das glaube ich auch nicht. Ja, also weil ich meine, ich kenne auch irgendwie Schwule und Lesben und ich feiere auch gerne mit denen und hänge mit denen ab und trotzdem bin ich selber hetero und wenn das stimmen würde, dann müsste ich nach dem ersten Blick in schwulen Magazinen irgendwie inzwischen stockschwul sein oder so. Das ist alles Quatsch, also glaube ich hinten und vorne nicht.
Naja, trotzdem, die Diskussion wurde dann relativ emotional weitergeführt und von allein hat sie ja angekündigt, sie wolle halt was tun. Allerdings hat sie ja zu Beginn auch überhaupt nicht davon geredet, dass jetzt Gesetze entstehen sollen, sondern es war ja eigentlich erst mal nur die Rede, dass man da die Kooperation mit den Internet-Provider sucht, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Genau, sie hat sich eigentlich gedacht, dass man das mit einem Vertrag einfach macht. Der Bund oder das BKA schließt einen Vertrag mit den Provider und die verpflichten sich freiwillig irgendwelche Inhalte, die sie nicht prüfen dürfen, die ihnen das BKA zu ruft, zu unterdrücken. Also das ist ja nichts anderes. So eine Sperre, da bekommt man halt nicht mehr zu sehen, was da eigentlich zu sehen sein sollte. Und natürlich, ja, so haben wir ja vorhin schon drüber gesprochen, niemand will so was im Netz stehen, haben dokumentierten Missbrauch von Kindern und so. Aber es zu sperren ist halt einfach der falsche Weg. Man muss es halt wirklich aus dem Netz entfernen. Man muss das Übel halt an der Wurzel packen. Ja, ich tu ja auch über das Unkraut in meinem Garten keine Tüte stülpen, sondern ich versuche es auszureißen. Und naja, Frau von der Leyen schlägt vor, dass wir da ganz viele Tüten drüber stülpen. Und dann sehen wir das Unkraut nicht mehr und alles ist gut. Aber das wird halt...
Kleine Stoppschilder, Unkraut verboten.
Ja, genau. Kleine Stoppschilder.
Erinnert mich an so ein schönes Titelbild von der Titanik noch aus den 80er Jahren. Bonn rettet den Wald. Stimmt, ja, so was gab es. So Waldsterben verboten.
In dem Zusammenhang noch zur Frau von der Leyen. Ich glaube, Frau von der Leyen, also das hat mir ein Betroffener erzählt, der hat mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass die Frau von der Leyen im Prinzip nicht das Problem Genderpornografie an sich lösen möchte und lösen will, weil sonst hätte sie ja drei Jahre Zeit gehabt, die internationale Zusammenarbeit, die Ausstattung der Ermittler und so weiter zu verbessern oder darauf hinzuwirken, hat sie ja alles nicht gemacht. Ganz im Gegenteil, sie hat Beratungseinrichtungen, Gelder gestrichen, sie hat Therapieplätze gestrichen, sie hat alle möglichen Sachen gemacht, dass die Betroffenen es heute viel schwieriger haben, damit zurechtzukommen und Hilfe zu finden, die eben auch angemessen und professionell ist. Und jetzt kurz vor der Wahl kommt sie da mit ihrer Nummer und im Endeffekt verhält sie sich, wie jemand in einer Familie, wo Missbrauch stattfindet. In einer Familie, wo Missbrauch stattfindet, ist es ja meistens dadurch die Situation dadurch gekennzeichnet, dass das weggeguckt wird, dass es nicht wahrgenommen wird. Die Mutter kriegt schon irgendwie mit, dass der Vater da mit der Tochter irgendwie sich komisch verhält oder so, aber will es nicht wahrhaben, schweigt und schaut weg. Diesen Fall sieht man ja ganz oft bei Missbrauchsfällen. Und damit löst man das Problem für sich selber. Für sich selber drückt man das Problem weg. Man will davon nichts wissen, aber man löst nicht das Problem an sich und schon gar nicht das Problem für das betroffene Kind oder so, sondern man schiebt es einfach nur für sich hinter den Berg. Und diese Scheuklappen fürs Internet, diese Stoppschilder, die da die von der Leyen diskutiert, das ist auch nur eine Lösung für einen selber. Die Frau von der Leyen sieht dann keine Kinderpornografie mehr im Internet, weil sie sieht ja nur noch das Stoppschild. Aber das Problem an sich ist eigentlich nicht behoben. Insofern ist das Verhalten ähnlich wie in einer Missbrauchsfamilie, was auch ganz schön krass ist für eine Ministerin, die es eigentlich besser wissen müsste.
Aber wenn man also mal nachbohrt und diese Vorwürfe auch so konkret formuliert, dann kommt ja immer schnell diese ausweichende Antwort, nein, nein, nein, wir wollen ja auch ansonsten eine Menge tun. Aber das ist ja für uns sozusagen jetzt nur noch eine flankierende Maßnahme, wo wir sozusagen den Content nicht aus dem Netz kriegen, dass wir da sozusagen auch noch die Möglichkeit haben, die Kinder zu schützen, dadurch, dass man sozusagen die Verbreitung der Bilder von ihnen nicht noch weiter fördert, indem man sie sozusagen durchlässt.
Ja, das wird immer gesagt, aber wenn man sich das mal genau anguckt, dann bricht diese Argumentationen zusammen, also flankieren, flankieren zu was denn?
Naja, ist die Frage.
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Also sie sagt ja dann auch oder hat in letzter Zeit auch vermehrt gesagt, naja, unser oberstes Ziel ist ja immer noch, die Server offline zu nehmen und die Täter zu finden und die Opfer zu finden, um ihnen für den Fall, dass es noch andauert, eben da helfen zu können. Und in dem Bereich ist nichts passiert und in dem Bereich gibt es auch keine Anstrengungen. Sie sagen, wir haben, also in der letzten in dem Spiegel-Interview von der Frau von der Leyen von vor ein paar Tagen steht, sagt sie ja, dass sie die Arbeiten zur Abschaltung von solchen Servern weiter intensiviert hätten. Da frage ich mich, warum ich im Januar Listen gefunden habe, die über ein Jahr alt waren von den Skandinaviern, wo Dutzende Server in Deutschland drauf standen, die auch nach einem Jahr noch immer in Betrieb waren.
Du hast dann eine aktuelle finnische Liste bekommen, vor einiger Zeit.
Ja genau, die war nur wenige Tage alt.
Du hattest aber schon vorher eine finnische Liste.
Ja, ich hatte schon vorher die finnische Liste von Martiniki.
Und die hast du dann miteinander verglichen?
Nein, ich habe einfach diese neue Liste, die auf Wikileaks aufgetaucht ist, die top aktuell war. Also am 25. März habe ich darüber geblockt, vom 18. März ist die Liste aus, das war eine norwegische Liste übrigens, keine finnische. Und da sind erstmal ganz schön viele Domains drauf, die überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell sind, die auch nicht mehr auflösen, die gar nicht mehr in Benutzung sind. Also man könnte diese Liste locker um einen Drittel, wenn nicht gar um zwei Drittel, schrumpfen lassen, weil das alles veralteter Mist ist. Und da sind mitunter auch Server in Deutschland drauf. Und ich suche das gerade mal, die komplette, der mutmaßlichen deutschen Server steht hier. Ja, das ist jetzt wieder aus einer finnischen Liste. Genau. Und da sind 17 Server drauf auf der finnischen Liste.
Aus dieser top aktuellen Liste.
Ja, die in Deutschland stehen.
Und naja, aber was sagt das jetzt darüber aus, wie lange diese Server schon in Betrieb waren? Waren die dann auch in den alten Listen schon drin?
Ja, in den alten Listen waren auch so was drin. In den alten Listen gibt es insgesamt, also in den Listen, die über ein Jahr alt sind, die zusammengeführte, die wir ganz am Anfang erwähnt haben, aus Dänemark, Finnland, der Schweiz, Schweden. In dieser Liste gibt es 57 Server, die in Deutschland stehen. Und davon waren, als ich mir ein paar, nee 26, wenn man die Geparkten rausrechnet. Also in Deutschland gibt es immer sehr viele geparkte Domains von diesen Listen. Das liegt daran, dass einer der größten Domain-Verticker und Versteigerer auf der Welt eine deutsche Firma ist, nämlich Sedo. sedo.de. Und deswegen, wenn man die geparkten Domains nicht raushiltert, liegt Deutschland immer unter den Top-3-Ländern mit Kinder-Porno-Servern. Aber das sind in Wirklichkeit geparkte Domains, die nur deswegen in Deutschland gehostet werden, weil diese Firma eine deutsche Firma ist und die Server von denen halt hier stehen.
Ja, aber warum sind ihr dann überhaupt so zahlreich darauf vertreten, wenn die Domains geparkt sind?
Also die waren irgendwann mal online und sind dann so auf diese Liste gekommen und...
Mittlerweile ist da überhaupt gar kein Content mehr, sondern wenn man auf die Domain geht, steht da nur noch so, diese Domain könnt ihr kaufen.
Genau.
Die ist gerade nicht in Betrieb.
Ja, und sie ist halt immer noch gesperrt, weil diese Listen halt nicht aktualisiert werden oder nur sehr, sehr unregelmäßig. Und die Polizei bis heute anscheinend kein System hat, um zu gucken, wenn sich auf diesen Seiten was ändert, was sich da geändert hat und die das irgendwie wenigstens semi-automatisch tracken. Das scheint nicht zu passieren. Die gucken, wenn die die Info kriegen, da gibt es eine Meldung, zum Beispiel von irgendeiner Internet-Meldestelle oder irgendeiner Anzeige von einem Bürger oder so. Dann gucken die da drauf, sehen, aha, ist so, sagen wir, ist sperrenswürdig, klick in die Liste und das war's. Dann passiert nie wieder was. Also dann machen die sich noch einen Screenshot und drucken den aus, damit sie vor Gericht sagen können, da war aber wirklich sowas drauf. Falls sich jemand beschwert oder so und das war's dann. Und dann steht die Domain halt auf der Liste und runter. Wie, warum runter? War's runter? Genau, also so war's bisher und selbst Leute, die sich beschweren, wie der Martinicki, der ist ja dann offiziell zur Polizei gegangen und hat gesagt, hier, ihr filtert mich, wenn ihr was gegen mich vorbringen könnt, dann macht doch ein Verfahren auf, zeigt mich an, macht eine Hausdurchsuchung, ihr könnt meinen Server beschlagnahmen, der steht hier in Finnland im Rechenzentrum, ich kann euch die Adresse geben, aber genau das haben sie alles nicht gemacht. Sie haben kein Verfahren eröffnet, sie haben den Server nicht beschlagnahmt, obwohl er in Finnland steht, aber von der Sperrliste genommen haben sie ihn halt auch nicht.
Und auch diese anderen, da bist du durcheinandergekommen mit den Zahlen, aber 26 Server in Deutschland, irgendwie jetzt abzüglich der Geparkten?
Jaja, die ist schon bereinigt um die Geparkten.
Okay, das heißt 26, die halt tatsächlich unter Umständen aktiv auch fraglichen Inhalt enthalten, laufen, zumindest über einen Zeitraum von, was kann man jetzt als gesichert ansehen, von einem Jahr? War das eine Liste? Ja, ein Jahr vorher waren die drauf, ein Jahr danach waren die drauf.
Manche von diesen Servern laufen seit mehreren Monaten.
Könnte man jetzt den deutschen Behörden auch unterstellen, dass sie von diesen Servern Kenntnis haben müssten? Ich meine, die haben sich vielleicht diese Listen-Ausfindern nicht besorgt.
Also inzwischen ist klar, dass sie sich solche Listen besorgt haben. In der Bundestagsanhörung, gerade am Mittwoch, hat der Andreas Maurer vom BKA gesagt, dass sie sich im Vorfeld zu dieser Anhörung zum Beispiel Listen aus Skandinavien schicken haben lassen. Ob sie das vor einem Jahr schon gemacht haben, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich würde ja davon ausgehen, als Bürger, als Naiver, dass wenn es irgendwo in der Europäischen Union einen Hinweis gibt auf eine Seite mit kinderpornografischem Material, dass die Polizeidienststelle in dem Land, wo das gemeldet wird, also von mir aus jetzt in Finnland, dahergeht, guckt, okay, stimmt denn das? Wo steht denn der Server? Ah, der steht in Deutschland zum Beispiel. Okay. Und dann entsprechend, damit Nachrichtigungen ans BKA rausgehen von der finnischen Polizei, wo drin steht, liebes BKA, wir haben folgende Meldung gekriegt, so weit wir sehen können, steht dieser Server in Deutschland, bitte kümmert euch drum und sagt uns Bescheid, was daraus geworden ist.
Ja, meinst du, dass die Finn das an die Deutschen auch weiter reichen?
Ja, ich hoffe doch sehr. Also ich meine, nö, natürlich nicht. Das BKA redet da nicht so gerne drüber. Ich habe auch schon versucht, da anzurufen und mit denen mal zu reden, aber die wollen...
Aber ich meine, im einlichen Sinne schwierig kann es ja nicht sein, weil ich meine, jetzt bin ich auch mal kein Rechtsanwalt, aber Rechtshilfeabkommen zwischen den Ländern sind ja nun durchaus gang und gäbe, insbesondere in der EU. Ich meine, wenn es möglich ist, ein Geschwindigkeitsticket, was man sich in Österreich geholt hat, dann auch in Deutschland durchsetzen zu lassen und umgekehrt, dann scheint ja durchaus eine Zusammenarbeit möglich zu sein, wenn es denn um ein wichtiges Thema geht. Und offensichtlich scheint das Thema dann doch nicht ganz so wichtig zu sein.
Na, also, dass die sich gegenseitig informieren, glaube ich ja schon noch und so, ich glaube, die kommen nur einfach mit dem Ermitteln vorn und hinten nicht hinterher. Also, ja, ich glaube, die haben halt viel zu wenig Leute, die da irgendwie fähig sind, so was zu machen und zu gucken, ja. Also die haben…
Aber so viele Fähigkeiten bedarf es ja nun nicht. Ich meine, ihr seid jetzt diese Listen durchgegangen, habt die Provider automatisiert angeschrieben, das ist irgendwie ein kleines Skript, das ist ja auch keiner.
Eine Postgres-Datenbank und ein Perl-Skript, das wäre nicht…
Kein VODO, ja. Nichts, was nicht schon vor zehn Jahren als erste Webseite aufgetätigt wurde.
Programmierung, erstes oder zweites Semester. Aber anscheinend sitzt beim BKA niemand, der Programmierung erstes oder zweites Semester abgeschlossen hat. Also, wer muss ich jetzt, ist jetzt eine Unterstellung, weiß ich nicht, aber ja, das wäre super naheliegend irgendwie. Den Kollegen aus Skandinavien sagen hier, wir wollen eure Listen haben einmal im Monat oder immer, wenn ihr die aktualisiert, schickt uns die doch bitte auch. Na und die dann mal eben durch so einen Skript zujagen, was den Jungs im BKA sagt, hier folgende Server stehen höchstwahrscheinlich in Deutschland. Und dann US-Anfrage auf die IPs, Adresse aufschreiben, Streifenwagen, Durchsuchungsbeschluss, Beschlagnahme, also Beschluss zum Host da fahren, Rechner einsammeln.
Ich meine, es ist ja nun nicht so, dass man dieses Schema mit Rechner werden schnell ausgeschaltet nicht kennt.
Also Satire-Seiten klappt es ganz gut.
Ja, nicht wahr. Also es war doch vor einer Woche oder so, ein paar Tagen. Was war das nochmal?
Eine Stoppseite im Stile des Bundesinnenministeriums mit so dezenten Änderungen, wie das da Minister für Wahrheit stand. Und es war nicht nur ein Bild vom Schäuble drauf, sondern auch vom Schreiber.
Und dann wurde dann einfach mal angerufen beim Provider. Ich glaube, da gab es noch nicht mal irgendwelche Gerichtsbeschlüsse oder so.
Nee, da wurde einfach nur angerufen und gedroht und ein bisschen rumgekackt. Und dann hat der Provider vor lauter Schiss das Ding offline genommen.
Da geht das ganz fix.
Und ganz fix scheint es ja auch im Bankengewerbe zu gehen. Ich meine, das Phishing-Problem ist ja nun seit langer Zeit bekannt. Und es hat auch den Eindruck, dass eine ganze Menge dagegen unternommen wird. Ich meine, da werden ja auch Sperrlisten vorgehalten. Also wenn eine Webseite als Phishing-Webseite registriert ist, und das ist dem Google bekannt gemacht worden, und man verwendet jetzt einen Browser wie Chrome oder Safari oder entsprechende Plugins für andere Browser, die das dann auch unterstützen, dann wird man ja auch gewarnt. Wobei man wird von seiner eigenen Software gewarnt und nicht von einem Server oder einer Umleitung gewarnt. Aber wenn ich es richtig sehe, in diesem Phishing-Umfeld werden ja auch die Server wirklich abgeschaltet.
Also in dem ganzen Umfeld von Banking, Trojanern, Phishing, Malware, Verteilen, also so Schadprogramme, Viren, Würmer und Trojanische Pferde und was man alles so kennt. Da funktioniert das mit Unterumständen, also nicht nur Unterumständen, sondern in den meisten Fällen viel, viel besser. Also in dem idealen Fall von Banking, Malware, dauert es, ich weiß nicht, 4,3 Stunden im Durchschnitt, bis die Seite offline ist. Im Idealfall. Ja, in weniger idealen Fällen dauert das dann auch schon mal doppelt und dreimal so lange und so, aber die bewegen sich trotzdem noch innerhalb von wenigen Stunden, also bis wenige Tage. Im Falle von, also das sind Zahlen aus einer Studie der Universität von Cambridge. Die haben verschiedenen illegalen Content im Internet und die Halbwertzeit der Seiten, die sowas verbreiten und verteilen, mal wissenschaftlich gemessen und ausgewertet und gegeneinander gestellt. Und die kommen halt, also für Kinderpornografie liegt die durchschnittliche Lebensdauer von so einer Seite bei so knapp einem Monat, 24 bis 30 Tage.
Weltweit. Allschließlich Deutschland.
Und für Malware, die Banken angreift und online Banking und sowas, liegt es bei, ich weiß nicht, wenigen Stunden bis wenigen Tagen. Also in ganz schlechten Fällen dauert es schon mal eine Woche, bis so eine Seite offline genommen wird. Es gibt sogar einige paar krasse Ausreißer, da dauert es 12 bis 16 Tage, bis so eine Seite offline genommen wird. Aber dann sind sie eigentlich alle weg. Und naja, da fragt man sich halt schon, warum das bei dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch irgendwie einen Monat dauern soll, was bei einem Online-Trojaner für irgendeine Online-Bank oder so nur wenige Stunden dauert.
Ja, das sehen wir ja auch in der Krise. Die Banken werden immer zuerst gerettet, hab ich für den Eindruck.
Ja, also die Forscher haben sich das natürlich auch gefragt, wie diese großen Unterschiede zustande kommen, und in dem Fazit der Studie steht drin, dass ihrer Meinung nach besonders, dass die Organisation und die Vernetzung der Take-down-Regime, also der Organisation, die diese Abuse-Mails rausschickt und dann guckt, was passiert und dann wohl möglich noch mal ein Fax hinterher schickt, wenn da nichts passiert und so, dass die Vernetzung und die Organisation dieser Organisationsstrukturen das Entscheidende sind. Die Banken sind mit ihren Sicherheitsteams international vernetzt. Die haben kurze Dienstwege, die haben das bis zum geht nicht mehr optimiert. Irgendwie, wenn da einer von den Sicherheitsleuten, sagen wir mal, irgendein Beispiel bei der Sparkasse in Hamburg so was merkt, dass da irgendwie Online-Banking angegriffen wird, dass es einen neuen Trojaner gibt, dann kann der direkt seinen Kollegen in den USA oder in Russland oder wo auch immer anrufen und sagen, du hier, das steht auf einem Server, das sieht so aus, als ob sei der bei euch und dann kümmern die sich da drum.
Das heißt, man möchte eigentlich genauso was für auch für diesen Bereich von dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch, bräuchte man eigentlich ein Frühwarnsystem, wo die entsprechenden Stellen der einzelnen Länder, die sich da eben drum kümmern, einfach keine Ahnung, auf einer Mailing-Diste oder auf einem geklärten System zusammenhängen und sich da einfach gegenseitig diese Tipps zu schicken können.
Genau und also die brauchen halt einen kurzen Dienstweg, der halt schnell geht. Also man hört von vielen, die Österreicher, bei denen ist ja die Diskussion über Kinderpornografie im Internet und so auch gerade losgebrochen und die österreichische Polizei sagt zum Beispiel, dass sie nur für Sachen in Österreich zuständig sind und wenn so ein Server schon in Deutschland steht oder so, dann sind sie nicht mehr zuständig als Polizei und dürften als österreichische Polizei auch nicht dem Host da in Deutschland eine Mail schreiben, wo drin steht, du hier nimm das doch mal offline oder friere es ein, damit wir die Beweise noch sichern können oder das ist ja auch eine valide Nachfrage und dann dadurch, dass die Polizei in Österreich zum Beispiel sowas nicht darf und ich glaube bei der Polizei in Deutschland ist es ähnlich, das weiß ich aber nicht genau, was machen die? Die schicken es dann an Europol. Und Europol schickt es dann an Interpol und Interpol schickt es dann zum BKA, wenn der Server in Deutschland steht oder so und da passiert dann was oder es passiert nichts. Aber Interpol, Europol und die Österreicher erfahren nie, ob da was passiert. Es gibt angeblich keine Rückmeldungen. Es gab ja Anfragen an die Bundesregierung und auch an Polizeibehörden und so und die sagen, naja, wir geben das jetzt aus, wir wissen nicht, was daraus wird. So und das müsste einfach ganz anders organisiert werden und ein bisschen gestraft werden, dass die Polizei in Österreich, sobald sie davon Kenntnis erlangt, einen Ansprechpartner in Deutschland hat und auch direkter anrufen kann, ihm E-Mail hinschreiben kann und sagen kann, hier folgendes, das ist der und der Provider oder eben im Idealfall direkt Erlaubnis hat oder oder das juristisch möglich gemacht wird, dass die Polizei in Österreich auch einen Provider in China oder in Australien oder sonst wo auf der Welt darauf hinweisen kann und darf, dass bei ihm Material liegt, was zumindest nach Österreichsem oder nach Deutschem oder wie auch immer gesetzt nicht erlaubt ist und dass er das bitte offline nehmen soll und sie können ja parallel dazu dann auch, dass die Bundespolizei oder das Äquivalent zum BKA im jeweiligen Land ansprechen und Wir haben ja auch ein paar, die sich ein bisschen auf die ganze Welt bewegen und sagen, wir bitten um Ermittlungen.
Du hast ja dann auch so deine Erfahrungen gemacht mit dem Melden von den Bullen, da gab es da irgendwie so ein Interview im SWA.
Ja genau, ich hatte bevor ich diese Listen mit den Servern in Deutschland und so gepostet habe, ich habe ja auch noch so einen Insider-Bericht von jemanden, der sich anscheinend sehr gut auskennt in der Kinderpornoszene, geschickt bekommen. Ich weiß inzwischen, dass er an mehrere Leute ging. Es gab wohl noch andere Leute, die ihn auch bekommen haben, diese anonyme Mail. Ich unter anderem auch. Ich vermute, weil ich mich eben mit dem Thema befasst habe, diese Sperrlisten analysiert habe und so. Und ich habe halt einfach eine anonyme Mail gekriegt von jemandem, der sich Mr. X genannt hat, auch über so einen anonymen Remail-Service, wo er halt beschreibt, wie das so abgeht und wie diese Szene organisiert ist, welche technischen Schutzmaßnahmen auf den Servern üblicherweise getroffen werden, wie die Server miteinander vernetzt werden, wie das Waschen des Geldes funktioniert, welche kommerziellen Strukturen es in Osteuropa in der Vergangenheit gegeben hat.
Unter anderem diese LS-Studie.
Ja, genau, das steht da auch drin. Der nennt auch Namen. Der nennt auch wirklich Namen von Leuten, die damit involviert waren. Der nennt Namen von Banken, die geholfen haben, das Geld zu waschen und wie viel Prozent sie dafür bekommen haben. Der nennt richtig Insider-Details. Und dieser Brief, dieser Anonyme und die Listen habe ich, bevor ich sie in meinem Blog veröffentlicht habe, ans LKA geschickt, hier in Berlin. Beziehungsweise erstmal an die Polizei. Ganz normal mit der Über-Internet-Wache. Ist allerdings nie angekommen. Und dann hatte ich ein Interview mit dem SWR und der Journalist vom SWR hat nachgefragt bei der Berliner Polizei ganz offiziell über Pressestelle, was denn aus diesen Erkenntnissen geworden ist. Und daraufhin ist der Berliner Polizei aufgefallen, dass sie die Erkenntnisse gar nicht vorliegen haben. Weil das Tipp- und Hinweisformular der Berliner Polizei auf den Webseiten ihrer Internetwache mit längeren Texten wohl ein kleines Übermittlungsproblem hat. Wenn man da reinschreibt, mein Nachbar hat mir den Kühlschrank geklaut, dann geht das wohl noch. Wenn man da drei Seiten Text mit langen Domainlisten und einem mehrseitigen Brief reinpastet und auf Abschicken drückt, dann kriegt man zwar eine Registrier-Nummer für den Vorgang, aber der Vorgang kommt nie am anderen Ende an.
Weil das Skript explodiert?
Vermutlich. Explodiert, sich auf die Fresse legt und noch nicht mal eine ordentliche Fehlermeldung wirft oder kein ordentliches Exception-Handling hat. Irgendwas muss es sein. Auf jeden Fall hatte ich dann ein paar Tage später einen Anruf von einer netten Dame vom LKA mit der Bitte, ob ich ihnen die Sachen nochmal per E-Mail schicken könnte, weil es wäre leider nicht bei ihnen angekommen.
Oh Mann.
Oh Mann, ja. Hab ich mir auch gedacht. Wenn die alle so arbeiten, kein Wunder. Wobei, bei den Leuten vom LKA, die dafür dann zuständig waren, hatte ich eigentlich einen ganz guten Eindruck. Die schienen mir ganz interessiert, ganz nett und alles zu sein. Aber dieses Internetwachensystem, das scheint mir irgendwie, naja, es ist auf PHP gebaut. Eigentlich sieht man das schon an der UL, dass es nichts taugt. Aber naja.
Du kannst vor mir keine Diskussion losbringen. Aber vielleicht noch mal zu diesem Inhalt. Inwiefern war das glaubwürdig, authentisch?
Also ich habe versucht, die Sachen, die ich abklären konnte, auch gegenzuchecken, aus anderen Quellen. Und ja, es gibt, also ich glaube, immer noch nicht alles, was da drin steht, aber es gibt schon große Teile, die vermutlich so sind, wie derjenige beschreibt. Also diese LS-Studionummer ist gut dokumentiert. Da gibt es auch Zeitungsartikel und Wikipedia-Artikel und anderes zu. Das scheint wirklich so zu sein. Runter bis auf die einzelnen Namen von ukrainischen Staatsbürgern, die da involviert waren, konnte ich es nicht verfolgen, aber ja.
Also es ist zumindest kein Dokument, wo sich jemand irgendwie komplett irgendwas aus dem Hörn gezogen hat?
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Es hat schon einen Bezug zur Realität. Inwieweit sie dann im Einzelnen zutrifft, entzieht sich unsere Kenntnis und auch Überprüfungsmöglichkeiten. Aber dann wird ja dann schon auch von einer Szene, ich will jetzt mal nicht Industrie sagen, wird schon von einer Verbreitungsszene berichtet, die ja auch immer noch aktiv ist, aber die nicht in dem Sinne im Web aktiv ist.
Ja, nicht über Internetseiten. Also der beschreibt zum Beispiel, dass man sich bei gewissen Anbietern Server kaufen kann, also so gemietete Server, wie sie Strato und so Firmen auch verkaufen, Web-Server und wo man so sein eigener Root-Account ist, sozusagen.
Root-Server, Virtual Hosts.
Genau. Und diese Root-Server werden halt fertig verkauft. Man mietet die im Monat oder kauft die für ein Jahr oder irgendwie sowas und auf diesen Servern, da kann man sich hinverbinden mit so Remote-Desktop-Verbindungen, VNC oder irgendwie sowas in der Art, meistens verschlüsselt. Und auf den Servern würden sich verschlüsselte Container befinden mit entsprechendem Bildmaterial. Und man würde per E-Mail dann so zum Beispiel die Passwörter für diese Container bekommen und könnte sich dann von zu Hause über Remote-Desktop da einloggen, dort den verschlüsselten Container öffnen mit dem Passwort, das man per E-Mail bekommen hat und kann sich dann dort die Bilder angucken. Und das funktioniert natürlich ohne, dass man Spuren im Internet hinterlässt, weil alles, was man sieht im Internet ist ein verschlüsselter Datenstrom zu irgendeinem Server irgendwo, der auch bei irgendeinem Web-Poster steht und völlig, ja.
Das heißt, auch die Bilder als solche werden auch gar nicht übertragen, also sie werden sozusagen nur in dem Moment angezeigt, wo man auf diesen fernen Server schaut?
Genau. Sie bleiben immer auf dem fernen Server. Sie verlassen diesen fernen Server nie. Sie werden nie auf meinen Computer zu Hause übertragen, außer eben der Bildschirm, die Bildschirmausgabe des anderen Servers.
Das würde ich so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Internetfernsehen.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Und ich meine, wenn man zu Hause Besuch bekommt von der Polizei, dann finden die gar nichts. Das höchste aller Dinge, die die finden können, ist, dass sie eine konfigurierte Verbindung finden zu irgendeinem Server oder sehen, dass da jemand mit Remote Desktop auf folgender IP zugegriffen hat oder so. Aber was man da zu sehen bekommen hat, wissen sie halt nicht. Und wenn sie das Passwort oder die E-Mail mit dem Passwort nicht finden, dann kommen sie da auch nicht dran.
Aber wenn sie die hätten?
Wenn sie die hätten, dann gäbe es da durchaus Ermittlungsansätze, sage ich mal. Und das ist so eine der Sachen, die der beschreibt. Aber richtig beweisen kann ich es halt auch nicht. Und gesehen habe ich sowas auch noch nie, dass es sowas wirklich gibt. Und der sagt halt, wenn man dann so einen Account zwei Monate hat, dann würde man auch sozusagen ein Update bekommen und einen neuen Container mit neuem Material finden oder einen vergrößerten Container oder so. Das seien zum Beispiel so Sachen, wie sowas heute gegen Geld verbreitet werden würde. Das hat aber nichts mit Webseiten zu tun und mit offen zugänglich, sondern das sind hochgradig abgeschottete Communities, wo man schon jemanden kennen muss und auch wissen muss, wo man welchen Server mit welchen Stichworten oder extra Wünschen bestellen muss, damit man dann sowas bekommt.
Den Brief hast du dann in deinem Blog veröffentlicht, aber da ist er jetzt nicht mehr.
Nee, da ist er jetzt nicht mehr, weil irgendjemand hat sich bei der Eco-Internet-Beschwerdestelle in Köln...
Also Eco ist der Verband.
Der Internet-Industrie.
Die kleinen Internet-Service-Provider.
Genau, die tun so eine Meldestelle für illegalen Inhalte im Internet betreiben. Und da hat irgendjemand, die meine Blog-URL mit dem Brief gemeldet. Und die haben mich daraufhin beim BKA angezeigt, wegen Beihilfe zur Verbreitung von kinderpornografischen Schriften. Begründet haben sie das damit, dass es zwei Absätze gab in dem ganzen Text, der so drei, vier Bildschirmseiten lang ist, wo dieser Typ, dieser Insider, der das beschreibt, so Sachen sagt wie, ja, also die Mädels, die dabei LS Studios, diese Fotoaufnahmen, diese Posing-Aufnahmen gemacht haben, die hatten da auch Spaß bei. Und ja, manches von dem Lachen, was man auf so Bildern sehen kann, ist auch echt und sind auch immer wieder gekommen. Die Eltern wussten Bescheid und keine Ahnung. Das war nach Aussage der Eco-Beschwerdestelle Verherrlichung von Kinderpornografie. Und weil der Typ in seinen Äußerungen das in ein, zwei Sätzen oder von mir aus auch in drei, vier Sätzen irgendwie verherrlicht, bin ich jetzt der Verbreitung von so Material irgendwie schuldig. Angeblich. Naja, das hat sich zum Glück relativ schnell erledigt. Ich hab dann mit denen telefoniert, hab irgendwie das erst mal offline genommen, weil die gesagt haben, wenn sie es jetzt nicht offline nehmen, dann kriegen sie eine Hausdurchsuchung von BKA und die beschlagen haben auch ihren Server. Meine Freundin ist vor einem halben Jahr von einem Berliner Helm- und Schildkommando völlig grundlos überrannt und verprügelt und festgenommen worden.
Da war euer Bedarf an polizeilichem Masterhandel bereits gedeckt.
Der war dann schon mehr als übergedeckt. Und ich selber hätte ja gesagt, okay, dann sollen die mal kommen zur Hausdurchsuchung irgendwie.
Aber da hättest du den Hausfrieden nicht aufrechterhalten können.
Nee, nee.
Das kommt ja auch nicht so populär.
Da hätte ich auch einfach meine Freundin retraumatisiert irgendwie, wenn da morgens um sechs plötzlich das SEK in der Bude gestanden hätte.
Ein Brüche und Hausdurchsuchung, das ist alles nicht fein.
Ich hatte schon mal das Berliner SEK in der Bude, das ist nicht so witzig. Damals konnten sie nicht bis drei zählen. Sie wollten eigentlich in den dritten Stock rennen, sind aber bis in den vierten zu mir gerannt, haben bei mir die Tür eingeschlagen und meine Bude auseinandergenommen.
Nein.
Doch. Und der Menschenhändler, den sie eigentlich fassen wollten, der unter mir gewohnt haben soll, der ist in aller Ruhe aus dem Haus gegangen und verschwunden. Und sie hatten auch noch vergessen, vor dem Haus jemanden zu postieren, um den abzufangen. Also so Versagen auf ganzer Linie. Die falsche Wohnung gestürmt, den Typen noch entkommen lassen, weil sie sich nicht an die normalerweise üblichen Vorgänge gehalten. Und das Beste war der Name von der Kommissarin irgendwie, die hieß mit Nachnamen Tödling. Weiß nicht, ob da der Name Programm ist oder so. Auf jeden Fall, das war ätzend.
Oh man, und du hattest dann auch wahrscheinlich gleich im Haus erstmal das Problem, dass du natürlich jetzt...
Nee, ich war gar nicht da. Ich war in Schweden und eine Freundin von mir war gerade in meiner Wohnung. Die hat sich eine Wohnung in Berlin gesucht und ich habe gesagt, du, ich bin eh nicht da. Ich bin in Schweden und wohn doch bei mir und such dir ganz in Ruhe eine Wohnung, hast eine Woche Zeit.
Ganz entspannt.
Genau, und die war dann auch ganz entspannt, lag gerade mit ihrem Freund auf dem Bett und hat eine Bong geraucht. Und dann flog die Tür auf und das Berliner SEK stürmte mit Maschinengewehr im Anschlag. Unten im Rambock irgendwie durch die zertrümmerte Tür. Das Snowboard von mir stand hinter der Wohnungstür, das haben sie gleich mit zertrümmert. Als sie schon alle Personen gesichert hatten und ihnen schon langsam klar wurde, dass sie hier in der falschen Wohnung sein müssen, hat der eine SEK-Beamte noch mit Absicht die Bong zertreten, die teure 70 Euro Glasbong. Da habe ich auch nie Ersatz bekommen. Und also mein größtes Problem war, dass danach meine Wohnung komplett offen stand. Die Tür war eingetreten mit so einem Rambock, die war einfach in der Mitte gespalten. Ich war in Schweden. Die Frau, die bei mir in der Wohnung, meine Bekannte, die da gewohnt hat, war traumatisiert und ist erstmal wieder nach Hause zu ihren Eltern gefahren.
Berlin war doch nicht so cool.
Und naja, meine Wohnungstür war eingetreten von der Polizei. Die haben gesagt, okay, jetzt rücken wir wieder ab. Tschüss.
Das haben die auch nicht gesichert.
Nö. Ich habe auch gleich mal angerufen und gesagt, sie sollen jetzt wenigstens ein Streifenhörnchen vor meine Bude stellen. Da könnte ja jetzt jeder alles raustragen. Und da stand ja auch alles drin. Mein PC, mein Schreibtisch. Da war einfach voll eingerichtete Bude. Ich war nur mal gerade für zwei Wochen in Schweden.
Also du hattest eine Erfahrung, du wolltest sie nicht wiederholen. Ich wollte sie nicht wiederholen, nee. Das Dokument, um das es ging, also nicht bei dieser Durchsuchung ging, sondern jetzt bei der Abmahnung dann durch den Eco ging, das ist dann bei Wikileaks, glaube ich, untergekommen.
Ja, ich habe es einfach erstmal offline genommen und habe einen bösen Rant über die selbst ernannten Recher des Internets geschrieben. So nenne ich die Eco-Beschwerdestelle nur noch. Ja, ich finde es ist auch sehr passend, selbst ernannte Recher des Internets. Also besonders war die Take-down-Notiz auch noch so total unprofessionell. Da stand noch nicht mal die URL drin, die sie eigentlich beanstanden.
Also nur so das Dokument, nehmen sie es weg.
Jaja, den Brief. Also sie haben immer nur von dem Brief geredet. So, lustigerweise hatten sie das Weblog auch gar nicht gelesen und hatten überhaupt nicht gerafft, dass da irgendwie Listen mit Servern in Deutschland rumstehen. Die hatten sie völlig übersehen. Wie, was für Serverlisten? Nee, wir haben jetzt sie beim BKA angezeigt. Super, Leute.
Dann sind wir wieder bei dem Mem mit dem Überbringer der schlechten Nachricht.
Genau, Shoot the Messenger. Auf jeden Fall irgendeiner meiner Leser vermute ich jetzt mal, hatte in weiser Voraussicht schon eine Sicherheitskopie gezogen, ein paar Stunden später, nachdem ich es nicht mehr auf meiner Seite hatte, war es auf jeden Fall auf Wikileaks. Und man kann heute noch in Wikileaks sehen, dass die Kopie, die dort steht, auch wirklich aus meinem Blog gezogen ist, weil ich hatte unter dem Text noch eine Ergänzung an, eine Anmerkung mit Links zu der entsprechenden Wikipedia-Story und zu einer anderen Story, die in dem Text erwähnt wurden, aber nicht verlinkt waren oder wo die links nicht dabei waren als...
Indiz, dass da auch was dran ist.
Ja, noch zugefügt und die wurden mitkopiert auf Wikileaks. Die stehen bis heute auch auf Wikileaks noch unten unter dem Text. Und das sind Ergänzungen, die ich eigentlich vorgenommen habe.
Du hast das da nicht hingestellt bei Wikileaks, sondern jemand hat das da hingestellt.
Aber aus meinem Blog kopiert gehabt.
Ja, wenn es nämlich einmal veröffentlicht ist, ist es veröffentlicht. Ja, vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen auf die Diskussion rund um die geplanten Internetsperren. Da ging es ja dann auch irgendwie immer weiter und die Diskussion wurde auch ein bisschen heftiger. Dann kam, glaube ich, dann war es auch, glaube ich, so der Fall mit dem Taus. Udo Vetter hat da auch noch einen interessanten Text veröffentlicht im Lore-Blog, wie denn diese Szene funktioniert und wie sie nicht funktioniert mit seinen eigenen Erfahrungen.
Ja, den hat auch, glaube ich, gestört, dass die Frau Ministerin immer wieder von der Millionenindustrie redet mit den Millionen oder gar Milliarden Umsätze. Es gibt ja wirklich, also die Leute von Innocence in Danger behaupten ja auf ihrer Homepage, dass mit Kinderpornografie im Jahr 23 Milliarden Dollar Umsatz gemacht werden würden.
23.
23 Milliarden. Also ich habe mal versucht, das auf die bekannten Listen, die auf internationalen Sperrlisten stehen, runterzurechnen, wie groß so der Return on Click sein müsste. Also wenn die das schaffen, ja, dann frage ich mich, warum die Leute noch nicht irgendwie die Chefs von Amazon und Google geworden sind, weil davon träumen die nachts, so einen Turnover zu haben mit Clickrate to money, ja.
Also 23 Millionen, ich meine, wenn solche Geldströme auch unterwegs werden, ich meine, der muss ja dann im Internet auch irgendwie eingesammelt werden, dann müssen irgendwie Kreditkartenzahlungen, andere Sachen, das ist ja auch gar nicht die Methode.
Ja, also den Zahlen von Innocence in Danger hat ja irgendwie einen Gasblock auf blog.odem.org, Gasblock-Eintrag mal nachgeforscht. Und die kommen letztendlich, also das geht über ganz viele Ecken, und letztendlich kommen sie von einem amerikanischen Filterhersteller, der Filtersoftware fürs Internet schreibt.
Der hat sie veröffentlicht. Das heißt, man geht da sozusagen einer anderen Industrie auf den Leim?
Ja, Hand in Hand mit der Industrie, die, wenn solche Gesetze irgendwie weiter um sich greifen, sich da halt einen Gesetz zum Gelddrucken versprechen irgendwie.
Ja, wo wir jetzt nochmal bei Wikileaks und Hausdurchsuchungen waren, zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es ja auch eine Hausdurchsuchung.
Beim Domaininhaber der deutschen Wikileaks-Domain, genau. Wegen den Sperrlisten. Also, soweit ich weiß, wurde diese Hausdurchsuchung gemacht, weil halt gesagt wurde, auf Wikileaks gibt es diese Sperrlisten zu sehen. Und das sind Links und da kann man draufklicken. Und nun, auch wenn das meiste irgendwie nicht entsprechendes Material ist, aber ein paar Seiten, die irgendwie so dokumentierten Missbrauch slash Kinderpornografie enthalten, gibt es ja doch. Und da kann man auch draufklicken und damit ist das Verbreitung. Und deswegen machen wir jetzt mal eine Hausdurchsuchung bei demjenigen, der wikileaks.de angemeldet hat. Dass der nur die Domain angemeldet und dem Projekt Wikileaks gesponsert, also den geschenkt oder zur Verfügung gestellt hat, das haben die überhaupt nicht gerafft. Oder es war ihnen egal. Oder es war ihnen egal, ja. Kann auch sein. Und dass der Server, wo Wikileaks draufläuft, nicht bei dem in der Bude steht irgendwie, haben die auch nicht gemerkt. Desen haben sie halt dann so seinen Laptop beschlagnahmt und so Scherze gemacht. Also entweder es war grandiose Dummheit oder es war oberfreche Repression irgendwie. Einfach nur, boah, dem geben wir jetzt nochmal eine mit, weil...
Also offensichtlich scheint so dieses Runterfahren der eigentlichen Server generell nicht so im Mittelpunkt zu stehen. Sondern immer nur dieses, alles was drauf zeigt, alles was irgendwie drauf verweist, was linked, was Domäneinträge sind, die irgendwie eine richtige Richtung zeigen, das ist dann schon problematisch.
Ja, ich hab so das Gefühl, dass die Polizei sich da im Internet immer noch nicht so ganz sicher bewegt und wohlfühlt und das irgendwie noch nicht so ganz rausgekriegt hat.
Also nicht nur die Polizei, natürlich auch die Gerichte.
Ja, auch die Gerichte, Staatsanwälte und so. Das alles noch nicht so richtig irgendwie denen den Fleisch und Blut übergegangen ist. Also wenn man denen sagt, hier könnt ihr Folgendes holen und folgende Wohnungstür müsst ihr dafür eintreten, dann sind die ratzap da und treten die Wohnungstür ein. Wenn man denen aber sagt, folgende IP müsst ihr runterholen, dann stehen die anscheinend erst mal wie ein Oxfam Berg. Gogo gaga tra la fiti?
Ja, der Verweis verwiesen natürlich hier auf den schönen Eintrag von Herrn Wiefelspitz, der sich in dieser Diskussion Gott sei Dank gerade raushält. Aber der will ja auch gar nicht so richtig im Internet diskutieren, hat er gesagt.
Ja, der ist ja auch nicht der Internetsperrenbeauftragte der SPD, sondern der Frisurenbeauftragte der SPD.
Aber jetzt, wo wir gerade hier bei dieser Problematik mit dem Linken sind, also generell merkt man erst mal in dieser Diskussion, wir bewegen uns jetzt hier auch so ein bisschen in der Zeitlinie der Ereignisse nicht unbedingt.
Ganz synchron.
Ganz synchron, spielt ja auch keine Rolle. Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass eben man wirklich gemerkt hat, die Diskussion kocht langsam hoch. Erst mal passieren natürlich am laufenden Meter haarsträubende Sachen. Dann kommen immer wieder kluge und dumme Kommentare aus vielen Seiten, die immer mehr Leute auf die Palme bringen, was jetzt gerade diese Linkproblematik und die Haftung auch für solche Links betrifft. Da hat ja die CT schon lange zu kämpfen, nicht wahr? Da gibt es dieses Urteil gegen Heise-Forumbetreuer oder gegen Heise, wo es um die Betreuung ihres Forums geht und die Haftung. Was ja darauf hinausläuft, dass man im Prinzip den vollständigen Content in so einem Forum die ganze Zeit überwachen und überprüfen muss und gucken muss, was da eigentlich getan wird, was de facto ja auch nicht zu leisten ist. Da kann man das Internet auch gleich komplett abschalten, das weiß jeder. Trotzdem gibt es solche Entscheidungen. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass ich mittlerweile so ein bisschen auch das Gedankengut schrittweise durchsetze, dass das alles Quatsch ist, trotz alledem. Heise war nun schon auch immer sehr, also insbesondere natürlich die CT-Redaktion, aber auch Heise Verlag als solcher war schon immer sehr sensibilisiert. Wir wissen, dass es ein Verlag, der extrem netz-computeraffin ist, der die führenden Computermagazine rausbringt und auch als Verlag selber auch immer schon sehr digital unterwegs war, wie auch immer. Es gab dann auch einen interessanten Artikel in der CT über die Verschleierungstaktik der Bundesregierung. Was war da so der Tenor?
Na, das Gute an dem Artikel war, also der Artikel selber hat wenig Neues zum damaligen Zeitpunkt in der Diskussion enthalten. Also Leute, die das bis dahin verfolgt hatten, kannten das alles schon, was da drin steht. Aber die große Leistung von diesem Artikel war, dass das so richtig gut auf den Punkt zusammengefasst wurde. Man hätte es nicht besser schreiben können. Es war einfach die Diskussion von einem halben Jahr richtig gut zusammengefasst. Ohne, dass man wichtige Dinge weggelassen hätte, ohne, dass man darauf verzichtet hat, Dinge, die jetzt vielleicht nicht jeder so weiß, der jetzt nicht seit 20 Jahren mit dem Internet rummacht oder so. Ja, die wurden schon auch erklärt. Ja, und trotzdem, also es war halt einfach eine super Zusammenfassung und auch was, was potenziell einem Politiker verstehen könnte. Mein Vater hat den Artikel zum Beispiel auch gelesen und hat ihn direkt verstanden oder hat ihm direkt eingeläutet, was jetzt da die Probleme sind und um was es da jetzt geht. Das war halt die eigentliche Leistung. Das ist äußerst lesenswert.
Eine wertvolle Quelle, die auch explizit Bezug nimmt, auch so die Vorgeschichte, weil wir hatten ja die ganze Internet-Sperrndiskussion auch schon mal seinerzeit mit Herrn Büsow in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Jetzt kommt das halt alles wieder auf. Ja, und drum herum hat sich natürlich auch das eine oder andere mobilisiert. Einerseits mobilisiert sich jetzt auch so eine neue Garde von Leuten, die sehen so, alles klar, da werden jetzt Sperrlisten installiert. Da könnten wir ja vielleicht unsere Interessen dann auch mal durchsetzen. Dann gab es irgendwie so ein Interview mit Herrn Gorni.
Wo war das? Also ich habe es zum ersten Mal gelesen in der Mobil. Das ist diese Zeitung, die da immer im Zug auslegt von der Deutschen Bahn. Also wobei ich bei denen ja auch denke, dass die eher Interviews verkaufen als wirklich journalistische Arbeit machen. Das kommt mir immer so nach Produktplacement vor, wenn ich das Ding in der Hand habe und so. Ja, da hat der Dieter Gorni, das ist der, na wie soll man sagen, Oberparte der Content-Mafia, also nee, der Vorsitzende des Deutschen Verbandes der Musikindustrie. Immer freundlich sein. Genau. Der hat da, ich kann das auch zitieren, Moment, ich habe das hier. Also er wird da gefragt, wie er weiter vorgehen möchte oder wie die Musikindustrie weiter vorgehen möchte gegen das Raubkopierproblem und so, und ob er weiterhin seine Nutzer alle verklagen möchte. Und dazu sagt der Dieter Gorni, der Vorstoß der Familienministerin zum Verbot von Kinderpornografie im Internet, ist ein richtiges Signal. Es geht um gesellschaftlich gewünschte Regulierung im Internet. Dazu gehört auch der Schutz des geistigen Eigentums. Und dann weiter eben nochmal auf die Frage wegen dem Verklagen und was er jetzt weiter machen will, sagt er, nein, wir wollen die Politik mit ins Boot holen. Denn was wir im Musikbereich zurzeit erleben, ist Teil eines viel größeren Problems, das immer mehr gesellschaftliche Bereiche betrifft. Das Internet verdrängt zunehmend alle anderen Medien.
Oh, das muss natürlich verhindert werden.
Ja, also sie versuchen da irgendwie mit der Politik in ein Boot zu hüpfen und über das Zugpferd, Kinderpornografie, mit dem Aufkommen des Internets ein noch größeres Problem als Kinderpornografie. Und naja, das sagt die Content-Industrie ja schon seit Jahrzehnten. Also als die Musikkassette erfunden wurde, haben sie gesagt, Home Taping is killing music. Und als der Videorekorder erfunden wurde, haben sie gesagt, dass Videotaping irgendwie Hollywood umbringen wird. Und ja, als der Computer erfunden wurde, oder CD-Brennprogramme und MP3 haben sie gesagt, dass MP3 irgendwie die Musikindustrie umbringen wird, jetzt zappeln sie immer noch rum, können die nicht endlich mal sterben, aber jetzt zappeln sie immer noch rum und sagen, halt das Internet killt uns alle. Und das Internet wird wahrscheinlich Hollywood und die Content-Industrie so viel oder so wenig killen, wie es der Videorekorder, die VHS-Kassette oder die Musik-Kassette gemacht haben.
Die Angst vor dem Internet, ich glaube, das ist an dieser Stelle auch wirklich ganz stark wahrnehmbar, auch in dieser ganzen Diskussion um diese Internet-Sperren. Es scheint einfach immer noch, oder mehr denn je, ich weiß nicht so genau, wir nehmen das ja immer ein bisschen anders wahr, aber offensichtlich gibt es halt einfach die Angst vor dem Neuen, die kennt man generell, und sie manifestiert sich jetzt sozusagen in diesem Monstrum-Internet, ja, was sich wie so ein Nebelwesen aus dem Rast hochzieht, immer größer wird, immer größer wird, und alles auffrisst, und alle Leute suchen halt jetzt jedes mögliche, erdenkliche Unheil in diesem Internet und verstehen halt einfach nicht, dass das Internet letzten Endes auch nur die ganz normale Gesellschaft, aber eben in digital ist. Und jetzt, naja, wann war dieses Interview mit dem Gorni, wann war das eigentlich?
Ich hab darüber geblockt am 29. März.
29. März, genau. Also Ende März, Anfang April. Und jetzt passiert ja auch einmal was ganz Erstaunliches. Also dann, Anfang April war ja auch die Republika, da gab's dann ein kleines Treffen.
Genau, also da gab's einen Vortrag von Alva. Hier, ich hab's jetzt hier stehen, das Mobi-Ding, in der ich's gelesen hab, war Ausgabe 03.2009, Seite 76.
Also März.
Genau, dann gab's die Republika, die war vor so acht Wochen, denke ich. Ja, da hat der Alva Freude aus Stuttgart, der war ja schon bei der Geschichte mit dem Herrn Büsow und bei dem Sperren von rotten.com und Nazi-Seiten.
Ja, also Internetfilterung ist bei ihm ja ein ewiges Thema schon gewesen. Alva hat ja ganz früher schon aus Spaß diesen Zensurfilter sozusagen mal als Kunstprojekt gemacht. Insert-Coin, genau. Genau, dieses Insert-Coin-Ding. Und im Prinzip hervorragend vorweggenommen, was uns viele Jahre später...
Bühnen wird.
Genau. Alva war auch schon mal bei Chaosradio Express und ist zu Gast. Da ging es halt auch um Netzzensur, Informationsfreiheit, damals eben noch die Novellierung des Telemediengesetzes, unter dem wir mittlerweile schon leiden. Und eben auch genau dieses Thema Haftung für Links, Chaosradio Express 29. Kann ich auch noch mal sehr empfehlen. Es ist zwar von Mai 2006, aber hat an der Aktualität eigentlich in den letzten drei Jahren nichts verloren.
Oft ist es ja total interessant, sich dann noch mal solche alten Beiträge anzugucken, weil man dann erst merkt, wie viele Parallelen es da eigentlich gibt.
Genau. Also kann ich an dieser Stelle, wer sozusagen da auch noch mal in die Hintergründe einsteigen möchte, wie das rund um Alva gelaufen ist, war ein sehr interessantes Gespräch, kann ich sehr empfehlen. Und Alva hat dann auf der Republika noch mal einen Vortrag gehalten.
Genau. Und da bin ich kurzerhand hingegangen. Ich wohne ja in Berlin, das war nicht so weit. Irgendwie Eintritt habe ich keinen bezahlt. Ich habe einen der Techniker angerufen und gesagt, du, ich komme jetzt mal schnell vorbei, lass mich mal rein. Ich will auch nur den Vortrag vom Alva sehen und bin dann wieder weg. So war es auch. Leider war Alvas Vortrag so im kleinsten Raum und der hat irgendwie den gleichen Slot gehabt wie Lawrence Lessing im Großen Saal. Und naja, das war halt suboptimal. Aber es waren doch 20, 30 Leute da. Der Vortrag war auch ganz gut. Die Vortragsfolien stehen auch online.
Genau, Thema, also Titel war Einstiegsdroge, Kinderpornografie? Warum Internetsperren nicht gegen Kinderpornografie helfen und wie diese als Türöffner für weitergehende Sperren dienen.
Genau. Und nach dieser Diskussion hat sich halt noch eine ganz lebhafte, nach diesem Vortrag hat sich eine ganz lebhafte Diskussion entwickelt. Wir standen da in dem Innenhof einer Kalkscheune noch ein bisschen rum, haben noch was getrunken und eben über das Thema geredet. Ja, und das ging so eine Stunde oder was und dann hatten wir alle Hunger und wir sind mit sechs oder sieben Leuten noch irgendwo in die Nähe was essen gegangen. Na und bei diesem Essen ist praktisch der AK-Zensur entstanden. Also bei diesem Essen haben wir uns überlegt, eigentlich müsste man da mal was gegen tun und das auch irgendwie ein bisschen koordinieren und alles.
Also ein bisschen auch analog zu dem AK-Vorrat, der sich gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erhoben hat.
Na erstmal hatten wir nur die Idee, einfach jetzt mal eine Mailing-Liste zu machen und der Ralf Benrat vom AK-Vorrat saß da auch mit am Tisch und hat halt dann gesagt, naja, dann nenn es doch gleich AK-Zensur oder so. Ja und damit war der Name geboren und dann haben wir uns noch ein paar Tage irgendwie noch ein bisschen angestellt und mussten uns selber erstmal darüber eben klaren werden, dass das jetzt vielleicht schon der richtige Zeitpunkt und die richtige Gelegenheit ist, so was zu machen. Und ja, dann stand es aber schon auf Netzpolitik irgendwie, dass wir jetzt einen AK-Zensur gründen und die Mailingliste gab es dann auch schon und dann ist das Ding zum Selbstläufer geworden. Dann haben sich plötzlich ganz viele Leute gemeldet, die man zum Teil eben auch kannte von ihrem Namen her oder persönlich gesagt haben, hier finde ich gut, möchte ich mithelfen und so ist da ja eine ziemlich gute Truppe irgendwie zusammengekommen und ich glaube, wir haben ja im letzten sieben Wochen auch gezeigt, dass wir da einigen Einfluss geltend machen können und haben ja die Diskussion durchaus nochmal ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung gebracht, als sie davor lief.
Es gibt auch eine schöne Ressource, dann halt im Web dazu, akzensur.de, dort ist so einiges dokumentiert. Allerdings sollte man auch nochmal eine andere Ressource hier nochmal nennen, dezensiert.de.
Genau.
Kannst du dazu nochmal was sagen?
Ja, da gab es jemanden, der hatte mich auch vorher schon angeschrieben wegen Infos, weil er auch in meinem Blog Sachen gelesen hat. Der schreibt glaube ich gerade an seiner Uni Abschlussarbeit oder an irgendeiner Diplomarbeit oder sowas im Bereich Jura und hat da wohl zum Thema Internetsperren was gemacht. Na und der hat, weil er das eh für sein Studium und auch für sich selber und so alles zusammengefasst und verfolgt hat mit der Diskussion um die aktuellen Netzperren, das nochmal schön auf einer Seite zusammengefasst und hat sich auch die Mühe gemacht, irgendwie eine Animation zu erstellen, wie so DNS-Sperren, wie sie angedacht sind, eigentlich funktionieren. Und ich finde, das ist eine super Seite als Einstieg für jemand, der sich jetzt noch nicht mit der Thematik beschäftigt hat, das zu verstehen. Und es ist halt auch so geschrieben, dass es eigentlich Normalsterbliche irgendwie verstehen sollten. Also das ist auch durchaus eine Seite, die man mal seinem Vater, seiner Mutter oder seiner Oma oder so nennen kann, die Interesse am Thema haben, aber da bisher noch nicht drin sind. Das ist halt ein ganz guter Überblick und Einstieg und erklärt irgendwie den Grundzügen ganz gut, um was es eigentlich geht.
Ja, aber dann hat sich ja im Prinzip die Situation auch ein bisschen verschärft. Es kam dann zu dieser, sagen, umwobenen Vertragsunterzeichnung. Also, dem sind halt verschiedene Sachen vorausgegangen. Das heißt, die von der Leyen wollte jetzt endlich mal mit ihrem ursprünglichen Plan, nämlich da einfach diese Vereinbarung mit den Providern zu erzielen, einfach durchziehen, wobei die Gespräche ja auch recht holprig verlaufen sind, wenn man so den Begleitenden...
Holprig ist noch sehr diplomatisch ausgedrückt. Also, ich meine, was da passiert ist, da wurde mit ganz bösen Tricks gespielt und da wurde ja praktisch Erpressung betrieben. Also, erstmal hat man die ISPs ja alle eingeladen und ihnen gesagt, wir würden da gerne mal mit euch drüber reden. Man hat auch so verlauten, zumindest von Leuten, die dabei waren und Leuten, die da bei diesen ISPs sitzen, haben gesagt irgendwie... Also, man hat sich wohl darauf geeinigt, Stillschweigen über das Treffen zu vereinbaren und darüber nachträglich keine Pressekonferenz zu machen und keine Inhalte rauszugeben. Die Provider haben das auch so gemacht und sind dann da rausgegangen. Und die Frau von der Leyen hat sich eine halbe Stunde später vor die Presse gestellt und hat verkündet, dass die Provider alle mitmachen bei ihren Sperrplänen und das alle toll finden, obwohl das gar nicht so war.
Da haben sie sich bestimmt gefreut.
Da haben sie sich gefreut, du. Die Provider waren da richtig happy hinterher. Die sind da praktisch an die Decke gesprungen und haben sich über uns Uschi gefreut, über Zensursula, wie sie einem Webnummer heißt. Das war erst mal so eine ganz hinterhältige Nummer. Na und dann wurden die halt auch offen erpresst irgendwie. So nach dem Motto, wer nicht für diese Sperren ist, ist für Kinderpornografie und ja, das sagen wir dann auch. Wo die Provider natürlich ein Problem hatten, weil sie nicht abends in der Tagesschau irgendwie von Frau von der Leyen irgendwie als die Unterstützer der Kinderpornoindustrie oder sowas dastehen wollten.
Da haben wir wieder das Problem dieser Stigmatisierung. Ja und wobei ich glaube, so wie ich gehört habe, war Vodafone irgendwie...
Vodafone ist da eine Ausnahme. Vodafone hat ein echtes Interesse an den Sperren anscheinend und findet das total toll. Das kann zum einen mit der Chefetage bei Vodafone zusammenhängen. Da scheint es auch mehrere Verbindungen zu so anderen Kreisen zu geben, die auch bei Innocence in Danger und zu so ein paar Adligen und sonst wie, die ganz gut sind. Und auf der anderen Seite, was das interessante Detail ist und wo wir dann auch wieder irgendwie zum Geld kommen, was ja meistens der eigentliche Grund für irgendwas ist. Vodafone ist beteiligt an Firmen und selber mitunter an der Entwicklung von Filtersoftware.
Ist denn das so ein großes Geschäft?
Im Moment noch nicht, aber wenn es gesetzt wird, vielleicht schon.
Aber das ist dann doch auch eher jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Vermutung als...
Ja, ja, das ist......legende Motivation. Das weiß man nicht so genau, keine Ahnung. Aber zumindest in Großbritannien ist Vodafone an so Filtersoftware-Entwicklungen beteiligt. Und das könnte auf jeden Fall einer der Gründe sein. Aber Vodafone scheint da so ein bisschen die Ausnahme unter den deutschen Providern zu sein.
Aber trotzdem ist es mehr als nur Vodafone. Es kann dann letzten Endes so die fünf großen Provider zusammen. Telekom, die ganze Liste, Aqua.
Aqua, Alice, Kabel Deutschland. Telekom hatten wir schon.
Ja, fünf Stück waren es, ne?
Ja, ich glaube.
Und die haben sich dann irgendwie zusammengefasst. Also, wen das übrigens interessiert, wie die Provider zu der Zensurproblematik stehen, es gibt da eine schöne Seite, zensurprovider.de, wo jemand mal angefragt hat und verschiedene Statements eingesammelt hat und dort wiedergegeben hat. Da kann man sehen, dass es durchaus auch Provider gibt, die das ganz anders sehen. Einerseits sagen, naja, wenn das Gesetz ist, dann können wir nichts dagegen tun, ganz klar. Es gibt auch welche, die sagen, wenn es Gesetz wird, dann sind wir sofort beim Verfassungsgericht, weil geht ja nun mal gar nicht. Da merkt man auch immer so, wo noch die Szene ein bisschen aktiv ist bei den Providern und wo nicht.
O2 hatten wir vergessen. Es sind die deutsche Telekom, Vodafone, Acore, Hansenet, Alice, O2 und Kabeldeutschland. Das sind die willigen fünf Zensurprovider.
Ja, trotzdem, die Diskussion ging da voran. Ich meine, da gab es halt dieses feierliche Unterschreiben. Das war in Berlin im Bundespresseamt. Interessanterweise, was das da jetzt zu suchen hat, hat sich mir auch nicht so ganz erschlossen. Auf jeden Fall, dort fand das irgendwie statt. Und dann gab es eine schöne Veranstaltung, wo, glaube ich, auch beide vertreten waren. Eine Mahnwache, organisiert vom CCC. Ich weiß nicht, war da jetzt der AK Zensur als solcher?
Nö, nö, nö.
Im Wesentlichen vom Club aus.
Und von Netzpolitik und so.
Genau, also aufgerufen haben natürlich alle. Im Club wurden dann fleißig Plakate zusammengeschustert. Das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert. Ich war da halt auch und ich muss sagen, das war der erste Moment und ich glaube, das ging auch so einigen so, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, oha. Oha, weil bis dahin war halt diese ganze Debatte so wie alle anderen Debatten, Debatten davor über das Telemedien-Gesetz und so weiter, wo man immer so dieses, man befand sich in so einer Szene, die wusste irgendwie mehr. Man wusste, dass es irgendwie alles scheiße und es stinkt. Und man wusste auch, das wird jetzt einfach beschlossen und dann wird es einfach umgesetzt. Und gegen vieles gab es auch schon Demonstrationen, auch so die Demonstrationen hier gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das aber ohne die Flankierung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts relativ wenig erzeugt hätte. Und gerade weil es natürlich hier wieder mal mit diesem Totschlatzargument KiPo einherging, hatte ich eigentlich relativ wenig Hoffnung.
War bei mir auch so vor sieben Wochen, als das alles überhaupt losging, habe ich gedacht, ey, mit dem Thema gegen so eine Medienmaschinerie irgendwie, plus Wahlkampfzeiten, eigentlich können wir gleich einpacken, aber das ist ja doch nicht so.
Genau. Und dann tauchten, keine Ahnung, ich meine, ich habe zwei Mal versucht, so durchzuzählen, meine Erschätzung waren, dass das schon so 300, 400, 500 Leute waren, die da aufgekreuzt sind, also echt nicht wenig, vor allem noch so früh. Das war irgendwie morgens um 9 oder so. 9.30 war es, glaube ich. Also für die einschlägige Szene wirklich ein Test. Trotzdem, sie tauchten dort alle auf und standen mit ihren Plakaten da herum und die Presse war begeistert und hat auch ordentlich gefragt und gefilmt. Und die Bilder sind ja auch heute immer wieder noch teillieglicher Berichterstattung, das merkt man. Und da hatte ich so das erste Mal so den Eindruck, aha, interessant. Also hier scheint offensichtlich jetzt der Bogen so weit gespannt worden zu sein, dass ein paar Leute einfach jetzt nicht mehr so richtig Bock haben. Aber erst dann in der Folge hatte ich dann so auch wirklich das Gefühl, dass das auch was bewegt hat. Also erst mal fand ich es interessant, dass es die eigene Szene soweit mobilisiert hat. Dann passierte auch erst mal wieder ein paar Tage lang nichts. Und dann gab es verschiedene Artikel. Unter anderem auch einer von Lutz Donnerhacke, auch Alter Haudegen der Netzszene.
Auf die 13 Lügen der Zensursula auf netzpolitik.org.
Genau, die 13 Lügen der Zensursula, wo halt einfach das alles zerhackt wurde. Das war dann sozusagen auch das Aufkommen dieses Zensursula-Namens. Der wurde irgendwie in diesen Tagen geboren. Ich habe es mir von Erdgeist abgeschaut. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ihm das eingefallen ist. Oder wo er sich das wieder abgeschaut hat, ist auch irgendwie egal. Das wurde dann irgendwie über Twitter. Hat sich das so von heute auf morgen zu dem Sammelbegriff entwickelt, der alles irgendwie zusammenfasst. Also sowohl den Protest gegen diese spezifische Politik repräsentiert eben von Ursula von der Leyen, die uns einfach alle so gegen den Strich geht, aber dann auch das Kernproblem in den Mittelpunkt rückt, nämlich, dass es hier um Zensur geht. Was ja dann auch immer wieder häufig dementiert wird, dass es ihnen ja alle darum nicht geht. Wobei ich das immer besonders befremdlich finde, wenn mir dann ein Politiker erklärt, dass es darum ja nicht gehen würde.
Also wenn ein Politiker zu einem sagt, niemand hier im Raum hat vor, eine Zensurinfrastruktur zu erstellen, dann spätestens seit Walter Ulbricht werde ich dann hellhörig.
Ich fand das sehr schön, dass der Herr Dr. Sieber in der Bundestagsanhörung tatsächlich von einer Internetmauer, die errichtet werden soll, sprach. Dass es ihm nur so rausgerutscht ist. Was ich meine ist, es wird dann so gesagt, ja, aber wir wollen noch gar keine Zensur machen. Und ich muss sagen, das glaube ich denen in dem Moment manchmal auch, wird das bloß so schade, dass sie das noch nicht mal sehen, dass sie das tun.
Ich sage dann immer, wenn ihr keine Zensurinfrastruktur aufbauen wollt, dann hört doch endlich auf mit dem Gesetz.
Lasst es sein.
Aber das sehen sie gar nicht.
Das ist ja was Gutes. Das ist ja für die Kinder und überhaupt. Dass die Kinder davon wenig profitieren, denke ich.
Das geht gegen Kinderpornografie und deswegen muss das ja per se gut sein.
Genau, wir haben ja auch schon gemerkt, das ist eine Sperre, die gegen Webseiten geht, die vielleicht unter Umständen, aber in den allermeisten Fällen nicht irgendwann mal, aber schon gar nicht zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, irgendein Content hat, der wiederum selber in den allerwenigsten Fällen mit tatsächlichen wirklichen, in dem Moment stattfindenden oder unmittelbar noch ermittelbaren Vorfällen was zu tun hat. Ausnahmen haben wir auch benannt, bestätigen an der Stelle auch die Regel. Und hilft am Ende gar nicht, geht vor allem auch nicht schnell. Das Beispiel mit den Banken zeigt, wenn man wirklich etwas dagegen tun wollen würde, worüber diskutiert wird, gäbe es andere Mittel und Wege. Dafür bräuchte man wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal ein neues Gesetz. Da müsste man sich einfach nur mal auf europäischer oder internationaler Anlassung, G20 genannt, hinsetzen und sagen, wir machen jetzt hier mal eine Taskforce und wir starten noch mal unsere Gruppen mit ein bisschen Geld aus. Kann ja nicht so viel Geld kosten, mal ein paar Computer zu kaufen, weil da scheint es ja auch ordentlich zu mangeln in der Ausstattung dieser Landeskriminalämter und keine Ahnung, wie es bei BKA aussieht. Wahrscheinlich auch nicht so sehr viel besser. So und diese Wut, die hat sich auf einmal kanalisiert. Die hat sich irgendwie manifestiert in diesem Zensursula-Namen. Und da wusste ich aber auch noch nicht, weil auch Netzpolitik-Org so wertvoll das als Quelle ist. Also eine Empörung alleine in den einschlägigen Medien reicht nicht. Und dann ging es aber los. Und das war dann für mich schon so das erste Signal, wo ich mir dachte, so, oha, das Spreeblick anfing mit diesem lackativen Streik. Wir machen jetzt unsere Webseite schwarz. Und ihr könnt euch jetzt hier eintragen. Da hätte man da so eine Google Maps mit so einem kleinen Fähnchen drin. Das hatte auch irgendwie noch so ein bisschen, hatte auch so was wunderbar Hilfloses in irgendeiner Form. Wir können jetzt nichts tun. Aber wir stecken jetzt mal hier nahe auf eine Karte und drücken einfach mal so unseren Widerstand aus. Und irgendwie, also ich will das jetzt nicht schlechtreden. Das war eine super Aktion, weil sie einfach schnell gezeigt hat, es gibt viele, die denken auch so. Und das war für mich so der Punkt, wo es dann irgendwie kippte. Wo ich irgendwie so den Eindruck hatte, oha, was kommt jetzt? Und dann kamen auch Sachen, mit denen ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet hatte. Ich glaube, so ging es dann. Also dann fing es sozusagen an, dass Sachen kamen, mit denen man nicht mehr gerechnet hat. Also ich meine, so einen Streik hätte man sich vielleicht noch vorstellen können, aber man glaubte halt nicht, dass es irgendwas bringt. Offensichtlich scheint es etwas gebracht zu haben. Dann tauchte auf einmal diese Gruppe auf dem Radar auf, Mogis, Missbrauchsopfer gegen Internetsperren, die sich explizit sozusagen jetzt hier gegründet hat. Ich weiß nicht, wann die mit ihrer Aktivität angefangen hat.
Also den Christian habe ich zum ersten Mal auf der Republika gesehen, bei dem Vortrag von Alba, so in real life. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es Mogis schon, allerdings noch nicht besonders lange. Die waren erst so zwei, drei, vier Wochen alt vielleicht oder so.
Okay, aber da hat sich sozusagen schon mal separat von den anderen Aktivitäten auch schon tatsächlich Widerstand geformt.
Ich glaube, in der Zeit gibt es ein Interview mit dem Christian Baals von Mogis. Und da sagt er, was für ihn der persönliche Auslöser war. Da gab es nämlich auch irgendein Fernsehinterview mit der von der Leyen. Und da hat die wieder so eine ganz üble Brachialrhetorik verlauten lassen. Und dem Christian, der ja selber irgendwie Betroffener von so einem Missbrauch in der Kindheit ist, dem ist dabei das Essen hochgekommen. Und das war für ihn der Auslöser zu sagen, hier diese Frau mit ihrer Brachialrhetorik, mit ihrem Verhalten, wie eine in deren Familie Missbrauch stattfindet und die nichts dagegen tut, irgendwie, die redet hier so ein Zeug und mir kommt das Essen wieder hoch, das geht nicht, jetzt muss ich was tun. Und dann hat er angefangen.
Ich glaube, vor, vor wir auch schon drüber geredet haben, nämlich das eigentliche Problem am Missbrauch ist einfach dieses Verstecken.
Und jetzt wird versteckt statt gehandelt.
Genau, jetzt wird das Verstecken im industriellen Maßstab als die Universallösung gepriesen und das ging dann irgendwie gar nicht. Dann haben die aber interessante Zahlen recherchiert. Da gab es eine Veröffentlichung von der Kriminalstatistik. Was kam dabei raus?
Ach genau, die haben sich die aktuelle Kriminalstatistik angeguckt, weil ja die Politiker und vor allem vor allem die von der Line immer gesagt haben, ja es gibt hier krasse Zunahme. Wir haben ja mal Fälle, das ist ein Riesenproblem, wir müssen da jetzt was tun, 111 Prozent. Naja, daraufhin hat sich der Christian und die Leute von Mogis diese Kriminalstatistik mal genau angeguckt und eben auch mal genau da reingeschaut, was denn da jetzt eigentlich alles subsummiert ist und welche einzelnen Straftatbestände wie aussehen und wie die denn im Jahr davor ausgesehen haben und so weiter und so fort. Die Quintessenz davon ist praktisch, dass die Zuwächse um 111 Prozent, die so gerne kolportiert werden von der Politik, nur auf eine einzige Aktion zurückgehen, nämlich die Aktion Himmel, wo es allein 12.000 Verdächtige gab, wo die überwiegende Anzahl der Maßnahmen eingestellt wurde.
Also Aktion Himmel ist glaube ich ein, zwei Jahre her und das war, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, eine Auswertung von Kreditkartentransaktionen, die gegenüber einer bestimmten Organisation durchgeführt wurden oder von einer bestimmten Organisation durchgeführt wurden, wo die Polizei sich mehr oder weniger rechtswidrig auch diese Kontodaten sozusagen bei den Banken erfragt hat und dann halt auch wieder mit der KiPo-Keule kam so hier, naja, wir machen was gegen Kinderpornografie, rückt mal raus. Obwohl es eigentlich erstmal so Daten sind, die so erstmal nicht hätten herausgegeben werden dürfen. Also ich will es ja auch wieder keine rechtliche Bewertung machen, da kenne ich mich nicht aus, aber wie auch immer, das war ja sozusagen in der Diskussion, dass das in der öffentlichen Kritik am Ende war, glaube ich, ist es keine einzigen Verfolgungen, konkreten Verfolgungen oder Verurteilungen gekommen, oder?
Also für Köln weiß man das relativ gut, weil die Staatsanwaltschaft Köln hat so ungefähr 500 Verfahren übernommen aus dem Himmelkomplex und die haben alle Verfahren, oder ich, von den 500, 496 oder irgendwie sowas eingestellt. Und die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass es in allen anderen Staatsanwaltschaften ähnlich läuft. Das Problem ist in diesem Falle, dass es auch hier, wie vorhin schon bei den Polizeibehörden erwähnt, keine Rückmeldung gibt. Die Bundesregierung und auch das BKA sagen zumindest, sie wissen nicht, wie viele Verurteilungen es gegeben hat, wie viele Spreisprüche, wie viele Verfahren eingestellt wurden sind. Die haben das zwar alles mal ermittelt und an die jeweiligen Länder und Kommunen und so abgegeben, an die jeweiligen Staatsanwaltschaften und Polizeibehörden. Aber was dann damit passiert, darüber gibt es keinerlei Aufzeichnung, das wird nicht dokumentiert und nicht zurückgemeldet. Man weiß es aus Köln relativ gut, weil die Kölner Staatsanwaltschaft dazu direkt eine Presseerklärung gemacht hat und gesagt hat, hier wir stellen das alles ein, das ist alles Kinkerlitzchen und lohnt sich nicht. Das waren, also da ging es nicht nur um Zahlungen, die hatten auch irgendeinen Webserver, wo sie Logfiles zu hatten. Also diese 12.000 Verdächtigen kamen dadurch zustande, dass es wohl 12.000 Hits von Unique IPs auf diesen Server gab. Dieser Server ist wegen seinem Verhalten, wegen hohem Datenvolumen, glaube ich, ich glaube sogar einem Host in Berlin, ich glaube das war sogar Strato oder so aufgefallen und die haben sich an die Polizei gewandt und die haben darauf hingemerkt, dass da irgendwie so ein paar Bilder mit kinderpornografischem Inhalt drauf sind und haben dann die Server Logfiles ausgewertet und über die Server Logfiles sind sie auf die vielen Verdächtigen gekommen. Und naja, es gibt auch Journalisten, die gerne wissen würden, was dabei herausgekommen ist, aber alle sagen einem, sie wissen nichts und was man im Prinzip tun müsste, wäre jede einzelne Staatsanwaltschaft in Deutschland danach fragen. Und zum Teil ist das auch schon geschehen, aber es gibt Staatsanwaltschaften, die, also relativ viele, scheinen sich dann dahinter zu verstecken und zu sagen, ja da gibt's Fälle, die sind noch nicht abgeschlossen aus dem Komplex. Wir können Ihnen dazu keine Auskunft geben. Laufen das Verfahren?
Auf jeden Fall hat sich Moges jetzt an der Stelle, es gibt noch einen interessanten Artikel, den habe ich auch gerade entdeckt bei Heise, zu den Auswirkungen von Operation Himmel oder den Nicht-Auswirkungen davon. Moges hat sich sozusagen jetzt damit als Organisation jetzt überhaupt auch erstmal da in die Sichtbarkeit gebracht. Und dann wurde die mittlerweile sehr berühmte und wohlzitierte E-Petition gestartet. Das ist ja so der neue Trend. Wir machen jetzt eine Petition bei dem überlasteten Petitions-Server des Bundestages, der immerhin, muss man sagen, mittlerweile wieder überhaupt erstmal beim Bundestag betrieben wird. Am Anfang war ja der E-Petitions-Server noch irgendwie in Schottland.
Bei der Universität von Edinburgh.
Ja, weil die das da mal gemacht haben und dann haben sie gesagt, ach das machen wir jetzt mal auch. Und das war dann noch viel unterdimensionierter. Da hatten wir dann mit unseren ersten Petitionen, mit Wahlcomputer und so weiter auch schon so unsere Probleme. Ich war so mit irgendwie, hat nur 26.000 Stimmen gezählt und danach mussten sie eine zweite Petition aufsetzen, die dann wieder bei null anfingen irgendwie und dann wurde das Ganze zusammengezählt und so. Also haarsträubend.
Typischer Fall von Software-Projekten, wo man kein Pflichtenheft vorher macht und sich das nicht ordentlich überlegt, sondern das so Learning by Doing, Banana Programming.
Man will gar nicht drüber nachdenken wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ging das hier aus einer Berliner Netz-Community, der erweiterten zwei Mädels hier, die Franziska Heine und die Diana, die haben da zusammengesessen, mag glaube ich noch der eine oder andere auch noch beteiligt gewesen sein, die haben da irgendwie den Petitionstext in schneller Folge übers Netz ausgetauscht und sich da irgendwie einig geworden und haben die halt einfach mal gestartet. Und das zog dann erstaunliche Kreise.
Na ja, gestartet haben sie sie ja drei Wochen vorher. Die lag ja erstmal drei Wochen beim Bundestag und wurde begutachtet. Das dauert ja so drei, vier Wochen, bis so eine Petition nach einreichen überhaupt online gestellt wird. Also eingereicht hatten sie die eigentlich schon drei Wochen vorher. Aber dann war der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo sich die Petitionsverwaltung da im Bundestag sich das angeguckt hatte und gesagt hat, okay, das schalten wir jetzt mal frei.
Und dann hagelte es.
Und dann ging es, dann gab es Twitter-Gewitter.
Ja, da kann man sagen, da hat Twitter seine erste Probe bestanden in Deutschland. Also da wurde wirklich mal ein Thema auf die Agenda gesetzt. Also auch jetzt lohnt es sich immer schön, die Suchanfragen bei Twitter auf das Wort Lattenzauen, Zensursula zu abonnieren, weil da bekommt man einfach die ganze heiße Diskussion, die permanent auch irgendwie nicht abflaut mit vielen interessanten Hintergrundsachen. Also man merkt richtig, dass sich rund um dieses Medium, nicht nur dieses Medium, aber vor allem dieses Medium, sozusagen jetzt so eine eigene Arbeitskreis, der sich nicht so nennt, gebildet hat. Es gibt zwar jetzt AK-Zensur, das ist so ein bisschen schon die institutionalisierte Variante, muss man fast sagen. Und dann gibt es halt dieses nicht institutionalisierte, was halt sich auf Twitter rumschlägt und sich eben einfach nur über so einen Suchbegriff zusammenfindet. Das ist schon sehr erstaunlich mit anzuschauen. Ja, dann ist das alles jetzt schon hier eine nähere Geschichte. Die 50.000 Unterschriften, die quasi immer so als Ziel gelten, das ist ja auch gar nichts, was im Gesetz verankert ist, aber handelt es sich nur um eine Verabredung des Petitionsausschusses, dass man eben etwas dann als relevant ansieht, wenn es es schafft, 50.000 Stimmen innerhalb der ersten drei Wochen nach Freischaltung der Petition zu bekommen. Relevant im Sinne von so relevant, dass eben dann vom Petitionsausschuss dem Petenten auch ein Vorspracherecht eingeräumt wird, um mit dieser Petition dann im Ausschuss aufzutauchen. Das muss in drei Wochen erfüllt werden, wurde hier in drei Tagen, also dreieinhalb Tagen, geschafft. Und jetzt, wo wir hier sprechen, ist auch gerade die 100.000 durchbrochen worden.
Wir sind schon bei 102.000.
Wir sind schon bei 102.000 und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass das Ganze auch noch weitergeht. Das nächste ausgerufene Ziel, was sicherlich genommen werden wird, irgendwann ist da bei 128.000. Das ist nur, um auch noch den letzten Zweifel auszuräumen. Wobei diese zitierte Petition mit den 128.000, die ist insofern sehr fragwürdig, als dass die eben zu einem Zeitpunkt zustande kam, als das Petitionssystem noch nicht in meiner Lage war, also wo es diese Anmeldung per E-Mail nicht gab, wo einfach jeder da im Web mal eben was unterschreiben konnte, wo es also noch sehr einfach war, für viele Leute da mal eben auch mehrere Stimmen abzusetzen. Ich sage nicht, dass das passiert ist, aber das muss man natürlich noch mit einberechnen. Seitdem sind viele Petitionen nicht so hochgekommen, wobei da war die Forderung halt auch Halbierung des Benzinpreises und so. Ich meine, wir wissen alle.
Das sowas zieht immer, oder?
Sowas zieht immer und der politische Wille dieser dahinter versammelten Masse, den wage ich in Zweifel zu ziehen. Naja, wie auch immer. Nicht in Zweifel zu ziehen, ist der politische Wille hinter dieser Petition, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben. Ich denke, das spricht schon ein deutliches Bild. Und es ist doch sehr erstaunlich, dass jetzt auf einmal das Netz offensichtlich auch Eindruck macht. Also es zeichnet sich ab, dass das politische System, nachdem sie am Anfang erst mal kräftig widersprochen hat, also da kamen dann erst mal die 50.000 und dachten so ach, naja, das Internet schon wieder und so, was wollen die denn? Dann gab es dann, das war wahrscheinlich auch der größte Fehler, den sie machen konnten, nicht diese Kommentare. Also von allein hat sich noch vergleichsweise diplomatisch ausgedrückt, aber da war es dann unser Wirtschaftsminister hier.
Ach ja, gut, ein Zwerg.
Ja, Wilhelm. Ich finde, man sollte ihn nur noch Wilhelm nennen, weil das irgendwie der einzige Name ist, den er irgendwie nicht in seiner Vornamenliste hat. Und Wilhelm meinte halt, ja, das war wieder so eine windige Formulierung. Er würde sich ja, jetzt grüße ich mich nicht zusammen, er würde es ja sehr bedenklich finden, sehr bedauerlich finden, dass es so... Wenn der pauschale Eindruck entstehen könnte, dass man ja gegen die Einführung von Kinderpornografie sperren sollte oder sich irgendwie... Also, hätte man jetzt auch schwurbeliger kaum formulieren können, zwischen den Zeilen gelesen und so wurde es dann auch im Netz verstanden, halt einfach dieses, ihr seid ja für Kinderporno, ihr widerlichen Leute geht weg. Das war sicherlich der größte Fehler, den man an der Stelle dann machen könnte in seiner Position. Weil da hatte ich dann wirklich so den Eindruck, dass alle so in den zweiten Gang geschaltet haben.
Ja, also ich meine, so was lässt man sich von so einem neuen Wirtschaftsminister ja nicht einfach so erzählen.
Also vorher war es wirklich so, man wollte irgendwie Eindruck erwecken und man wollte irgendwie gehört werden und man wollte irgendwie was klingeln lassen. Und nach diesem Statement ist es jetzt so, dass eigentlich alle auf Rambock-Modus geschaltet haben, gesagt haben, jetzt hauen wir so lange auf euch ein, bis ihr weg seid. Also nicht, wenn die Regierung weg ist, sondern bis dieser Gesetzesentwurf zusammengefaltet ist. Du teilst diese ein?
Ja, ja, ich teile den Eindruck. Und also für all diejenigen, die das hier hören und jetzt noch nicht unterschrieben haben, die Petitionen gegen die Internetsperren, www.zeichnemit.de.
Stimmt, das ist eine der mehreren Aktivitäten, die diese Petitionen unterstützen. Da hat sich dann natürlich auch einiges, es gibt auch den Admit-Zeichner auf Twitter zum Abonnieren und dann gibt es dann immer schöne Grafiken und so. Also mittlerweile entfaltet sich da auch noch so ein eigenes Dienstleistungsuniversum rund um diese Petitionen. Ja, und ich denke auch, dass es an dieser Stelle auch wirklich angemessen ist, auch nochmal aufzurufen, da drüber nachzudenken. Ihr solltet darüber nachdenken, dazu unterschreiben, wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt, oder vielleicht auch mal versuchen, mit jemandem zu diskutieren, das zu tun, was nicht so einfach ist. Das habe ich auch gemerkt. Es gab ja jetzt auch vor ein paar Tagen so den Aufruf, so jeder, der unterschrieben hat, der muss jetzt normalen rein. Ja, dann habe ich es halt mal so im familiären Kontext probiert. Das gestaltet sich sehr schwierig. Merkt man doch schnell, weil bei dieser KiPo-Thematik gehen einfach die Schollklappen runter. Das ist so dieses einfach, das kann doch alles nicht so wichtig sein da mit eurer Freiheit und so. Und auch aus so politischen Kreisen hört man ja schnell so diese Formulierung, na ja, die Community, die will ja einfach immer nur, dass immer alles frei zugänglich ist und so und dann dieses, dieser Mythos mit dem rechtsfreien Raum, ja ihr wollt ja, dass das Internet frei von rechtlichen Maßnahmen ist, wie man eigentlich widersprechen kann.
Erstens ist das Internet kein Raum und rechtsfrei ist es auch nicht.
Ja, das hat auch jeder verstanden und ich denke, das wünscht sich auch niemand wirklich. Ich war, das wäre noch schöner.
Ich meine, das Internet hatte schon sowas wie Rechtsnormen, da wussten die Politiker noch gar nicht, wie man Internet buchstabiert.
Dass es das gibt.
Und dass es das gibt.
Was meinst du jetzt, sowas wie eine Netiquette oder so?
Ja, zum Beispiel. Und auch irgendwie...
Also Rechtsnormen ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es gab... man hat sich Regeln...
Na, auch die Sache, dass es Abuse-Accounts gibt und dass es die eigentlich immer gibt und dass die immer erreichbar sind und so.
Aber bei Convention halt, ne?
Jaja, okay. Aber ich meine...
Immerhin.
Das ist ja auch ein neues Medium und in anderen Kulturkreisen oder sonstiges... Das Internet ist so entscheidend. Das sind ja auch unsere Gesetze und Regeln und gesellschaftlichen Normen irgendwann mal bei Convention entstanden.
Aber ja, noch mal zu den Auswirkungen. Dort ist erwähnt, im Vorfeld, jemand hat sich auch mal die Schweizer Zensurlisten bzw. hat sich Schweizer Zensurlisten zusammengebaut, indem er sich die anderen genommen hat und einfach mal abgeklopft hat.
Ja, genau. Einer meiner Leser, also einer meiner Scusi-Block-Leser hat irgendwie was Lustiges gemacht. Der hat halt gesehen, dass ich diese Listen zusammengeführt habe und mal noch Server-Standorten analysiert habe. Und in der Schweiz wird ja auch gefiltert. Und also gibt es da auch so DNS-Sperren gegen Kinderpornografie. Und der hat sich halt dann einfach mal meine Liste genommen. Die zusammengeführte aus Dänemark und sonst wie. Da waren ja auch Teile der Schweizer Liste drauf und hat die bei sich noch mal durchlaufen lassen. Also der hat sich einfach so einen Einzeiler auf der Shell geschrieben und da die Liste reingepackt und die nach NS-Lookup gepiped und das Ergebnis wieder in eine Textdatei geschrieben. Und hat dann eine Liste der Schweizer im Moment blockierten Domains gehabt oder zumindest einen großen Teil davon. Ob die vollständig ist, wissen wir nicht. Ja, das war die erste Aktion, die einer aus der Schweiz gemacht hat. Und jetzt vor zwei, drei Wochen habe ich noch mal eine Mail aus der Schweiz gekriegt, wo ein Leser dieses ursprünglichen Eintrags gesagt hat, hier, ich habe das jetzt noch mal gemacht und ich habe das jetzt einmal zu Hause gemacht und einmal eben in der Firma. Und zum ersten ist dabei rausgekommen, dass von den 871 waren es, glaube ich, Schweizer Domains, die auf dieser Schweizer Liste standen, ganz, ganz viele rausgefallen sind. Den aktuellen Teil der Schweizer Zensurliste, den wir öffentlich kennen, besteht jetzt nur noch aus 500 ein paar gequetschten Domains. Also wir haben da mal fast die Hälfte rausgeschmissen. Was auch dringend nötig war, weil das wären die ganzen geparkten Domains und alles gewesen sein und die, die eh nicht mehr funktioniert haben.
Das ist schon interessant. Also offensichtlich fühlen sich jetzt im Schatten dieser Diskussion einige Stellen doch schon aufgefordert, dann vielleicht auch mal zu überprüfen, was sie da tun.
Ja und das andere Interessante, was derjenige rausgefunden hat, war, dass in den Businessnetzen die Businesskunden vermietet werden. Also Geschäftskunden haben ja meistens auch andere Zugänge und oft auch eine feste IP und keine dynamische und sowas. Für die Geschäftskunden werden in der Schweiz bei manchen Providern andere Domains gefiltert als bei den Privatkunden. Es scheint so zu sein, dass bei den Privatkunden umfangreicher gefiltert wird und einige Domains, die bei Privatkunden nicht erreichbar sind und in die DNS-Sperre laufen, für Geschäftskunden durchaus erreichbar sind.
Das heißt, es gibt nicht nur so die eine Sperrliste, die jetzt gegen ein spezifisches Problem vorgeht, sondern es macht schon den Eindruck, es gibt spezifische Domainangepasste, also Domänen im Sinne von Business- nicht-Business-Bereich angepasste Sperrkonzepte.
Es scheint so zu sein. Ich kann ja mal vorlesen irgendwie, was er schreibt. Habe mal die Defisk-Blablabla-Text-Sorted-Liste genommen und überprüft, welche der da angegebenen Hosts bei meinem Provider der Cablecom aus der Schweiz zensiert werden. Ergebnis, da kommt dann eine URL, da steht dann die ganzen Domainnamen, die er daraus geholt hat. Falls es irgendwen interessiert, gibt es auch noch die ganzen gepackten Dateien zum Download, also mit Logfile und allem. Merke gerade, dass im Schweizer IP-Plus-Backbone, in Klammern für Businesskunden, zumindest nicht alle der oben genannten Domainnamen zensiert werden. So ist a1-nft.wo.to zum Beispiel zu der folgenden IP auflösbar.
Das heißt, gut, aber es könnte ja auch sein, dass es unterschiedliche Versionen sind, dass die eine schon neuer ist und die andere ist schon bereinigt.
Könnte sein. Er hat auch nur Stichproben gemacht, weil er sagt, er wollte auf der Arbeit jetzt nicht die komplette Sperrliste gegen den DNS durchjagen.
Naja, um vielleicht auch mal langsam so zum Ende der Diskussion zu kommen. Die letzten Ereignisse fand ich auch sehr bemerkenswert. Dann gab es ja dieses Internet Governance Forum.
Genau, in Genf. In Genf, da treffen sich die Staatschefs der Welt nicht, aber so die Verwaltungschefs der Staatschefs der Welt oder so. Und reden halt über, wie man das so macht, mit dem Staat organisieren und wie man das jetzt auch im Internet so macht. Und was da so gut best practice ist und darüber unterhalten die sich, wenn ich das so richtig mitgekriegt habe. Vermutlich auch über weitere Themen wie so Durchsetzung der Urheberrechte weltweit, blablabla und so und so ein Zeug. Na auf jeden Fall sind da jetzt die Chinesen aufgeschlagen und haben ihre Freude über die in Europa und westlichen Teilen der Welt vorgehende Debatte zu Sachen Sperrungen im Internet irgendwie zum Ausdruck gebracht. Weil eigentlich sollte auf dieser IGF-Tagung in Genf auch Internetzensur, gerade in China, auf der Tagesordnung stehen und in so anderen Ländern wie Saudi-Arabien, Iran und so. Und da hat ein chinesischer Diplomat halt einfach mal ganz cool gesagt, Leute, ihr sperrt doch auch, ihr seid doch gerade auch dabei, genau dasselbe zu tun, wie wir auch. Wir sehen da überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Lasst das Thema mal schön von der Tagesordnung, weil sonst machen wir jetzt hier einen Fass auf. Und dann reden wir mal über Internetsperrung in Deutschland oder so.
Und damit war das Thema dann durch.
Damit war das Thema dann durch, ja. Also wir haben jahrelang, auch Deutschland hat jahrelang China kritisiert für, zu Recht ja, für ihre Internetzensur und ihre andere.
Was war da fein Aufstand? Oh, die Journalisten dürfen jetzt nicht umdrehen.
Was hat damals noch der eine, hier der deutsche Sportfunktionär, der Vespa, Michael Vespa, der ist jetzt irgendwie da beim Olympischen Komitee und war da auch dabei. Und der hat ja die Zensurmaßnahmen von China damals schon irgendwie mit denen in Deutschland verglichen und hat gesagt, naja, die Chinesen sperren halt was bei ihnen Illegales, Amnesty International und Falun Gong, und wir sperren was bei uns Illegales, irgendwie nsdapo.com und rotten.com oder so. Wo liegt denn da der Unterschied? Das ist doch beides dasselbe. Dafür hat er tierisch einstecken müssen.
Das sind jetzt aber die ersten Links, die hier erwähnt werden, die ich nicht in meine Linkliste schreibe. Das wird zensiert. Ja, wir müssen es nochmal sagen. Nicht auf rotten.com klicken. Nicht klicken. Nicht. Ja, na schön. Schöne Steilvorlage, nicht wahr?
Ja, da haben sie echt eine schöne Steilvorlage. Also wenn man sich anguckt, dass das gerade erst ein halbes Jahr her ist, wo der Vespa so fertig gemacht wurde, dafür, dass er das so verglichen hat. Ja, und wenn man sich anguckt, wo wir heute stehen und was chinesische Diplomaten, unseren Diplomaten auf so internationalen Meetings irgendwie ins Gesicht sagen und auch der Presse gegenüber nicht hinterm Berg mithalten, ja, dann haben wir hier schon eine ganz neue Qualität. Also mit dieser Diskussion haben wir der weltweiten Zensur von irgendwelchen Diktaturen und sonstigen so Regimen richtig Vorschub geleistet. Also einen besseren Freifahrtschein hätten wir ihnen nicht geben können, sozusagen. Und ganz nebenbei hat die Bundesregierung vollkommen ihre eigene Menschenrechtspolitik und so gegenüber China und Politik von Meinungsäußerungen und sonst wie. Ja, die haben sich selber gerade für ihre Politik mit China einen Knieschuss verpasst. Die haben das jetzt noch gar nicht so richtig realisiert, scheint mir. Aber die haben sich gerade richtig vor der Weltöffentlichkeit ins Knie geschossen. Und da frage ich mich halt auch, also ja, gute Diplomaten sind aber anders drauf.
Gut beraten scheinen sie auch nicht zu sein bei den Organisationen, die ihnen gerade so versuchen, da noch flankierend zur Seite zu stehen. Genau. Nämlich diese Deutsche Kinderhilfe, eine recht umstrittene Gruppierung, wo man, glaube ich, große Zweifel daran haben kann, ob die nun wirklich für das stehen, was sie glauben zu stehen. Zumindest gibt es so große Zweifel daran, dass ihnen letztes Jahr schon da die Gemeinnützigkeit aberkannt wurde, da Spenden einzusammeln.
Also ich denke, man kann sicher sagen, dass die Deutsche Kinderhilfe auf jeden Fall eine deutsche Organisation ist. Also ich glaube, mit Kindern haben sie nichts zu tun und helfen tun sie auch niemandem, außer vielleicht der CDU als Vorfeldlobby-Organisation.
Lassen wir das offen. Auf jeden Fall haben die eine sehr tendenzielle Umfrage gestartet, wo sie dann mal so ganz einfach plummt, naja, also die Leute gehen so vor Stadien und sammeln Unterschriften ein. Jetzt wollen sie da, glaube ich, noch eine eigene Petition starten, wo es dann irgendwie den Leuten sozusagen nur abgerungen wird, ob sie denn gegen Kinderpornografie im Internet sind, wo natürlich jeder Ja sagt. Das heißt, die erklären überhaupt nicht, worum es geht. Sehr schön fand ich dann eben die Gegenaktion von Moges, also nach dieser Infratest-Demap-durchgeführten Umfrage dann von der Kinderhilfe, so nach dem Motto, sind sie jetzt für Sperren oder nicht, wo wir natürlich alle gesagt haben, na klar, ja, 90 Prozent Sperren, wurde dann einfach eine etwas diversifizierte Geschichte gemacht, nämlich wollt ihr löschen oder Sperren oder nichts tun, und da sah es natürlich gleich ganz anders aus. Ich denke, das ist jetzt auch einfach so im Mittelpunkt, das setze ich mittlerweile auch langsam durch, da muss man auch nochmal darauf stärker eingehen, dass man einfach sagen muss, es ist eigentlich viel einfacher, rechtsstaatlich viel unkomplizierter und auch mit bestehenden Gesetzen durchaus durchzusetzen, dass man halt einfach direkt gegen diese Server vorgeht, da muss man gar nicht sperren.
Ja, was auch ganz wichtig ist, ist es unter Umständen oder in guten Fällen viel, viel schneller, also ich meine die Sperrliste kommt einmal alle 24 Stunden und zwar nur an Werktagen und kann dann noch mal bis zu 6 Stunden brauchen, bis sie entsprechend eingespielt ist ins System. Wenn wir das zusammenrechnen, sind wir bei 30 Stunden, also im ungünstigsten Falle dauert eine Aktualisierung der Liste 30 Stunden, das heißt, wenn kurz nachdem die Liste rausgeschickt wurde, so eine neue Domain entdeckt wurde, dann hat man noch 29 Stunden und 58 Minuten oder so, bis man die überhaupt sperren kann. In der Zeit, wenn man eine Abuse-Mail an den Hoster schickt, sind die meisten Angebote schon lange vom Netz. Also als der Alvar und der AK Zensur vor ein paar Tagen diese Aktion gestartet haben und die Sperrlisten dann mal durchgegangen sind und die Provider angeschrieben haben und so, da kamen die ersten Rückmeldungen, das hat keine 10 Minuten gedauert. Nach ein paar Minuten war der erste Provider in der Inbox, der gesagt hat, ja, habe ich mir angeguckt, habe ich gesperrt, vielen Dank für den Hinweis.
Wenn man nur will.
Wenn man nur will, klar. Also dafür muss man halt auch, also falls es in Deutschland auch solche rechtlichen Einschränkungen geben sollte, dass das BKA oder das LKA oder wer auch immer als zuständige Stelle, Ermittlungsbehörde, nicht die Erlaubnis hat oder die Möglichkeit hat, einem ausländischen Host da in Taiwan oder wo auch immer direkt eine Mail zu schreiben und zu sagen, hier haben wir gerade gefunden, bitte mal runter nehmen, Daten sichern, vielleicht brauchen wir die noch, Diensthilfe ersuchen an ihre Behörden vor Ort, geht raus. Ja, dann tut die überwiegende Mehrheit der Provider irgendwie sofort handeln, friert den Zugang ein, nimmt die Daten vom Netz und wartet bis sie irgendwie einen Gerichtsbescheid bekommen oder eine Aufforderung, die Daten eben ihrer Polizei oder wem auch immer zur Verfügung zu stellen und heben die so lange auf. Das ist eigentlich Usus im internationalen Providergeschäft.
Ja, und wer noch nicht genug Argumente gefunden hat hier in unserer Diskussion, kann auch noch mal die von uns genannten Webseiten nachlesen. AK Zensura.
akzensura.de, dezensiert.de, zeichnemit.de.
Das sind so mal die wichtigsten. Den Rest findet ihr natürlich wie immer in der Linkliste. Zu diesem ungewöhnlich aktuellen Chaosradio Express. Aber auch ich hatte den Eindruck, ich muss hier noch mal einen drauflegen, weil diesmal muss es einfach krachen. Gut, scusi.
Ich glaube, wir haben es, ich glaube auch, ich muss jetzt auch los ph-neutral aufbauen.